the house Judiciary Committee to
order this morning we are hearing two
bills House Bill 622 and
625 uh
contemporaneously and my plan this
morning is to call upon the sponsors of
those bills toh speak first and then I
will call upon those people who wish to
testify we do have a relatively long
witness uh list today number of people
who do want to speak in either support
or
opposition what my intention is is once
we give the sponsors an opportunity to
introduce their bills is to uh allow
people to speak but hold them to a three
minute time limit on their speech and
we'll be timing that to make sure that
they stay within the designated time
frame that will allow us to hear from
everyone today today if we didn't impose
that limit I'm not sure we'd be able to
finish our hearing today there is a lot
of interest in this particular subject
matter so uh with that uh we'll begin
this morning by as I indicated calling
upon the primary sponsor of House Bill
622 which I believe is representative
Stapleton and is representative
Stapleton available a point of Mr
chairman yes we need to take a roll
call oh I'm sorry and I need to read a
script
right and you're gonna have to bear with
me find that
script um also Mr chairman um
representative langle is in the
attendees um list and needs to be
promoted to
panelists
[Music]
thank you for reminding me of reading
the script too anxious to begin
today uh as chair of the house Judiciary
Committee I find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of the covid-19
pandemic and in accordance with the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically some committee members
are participating in this meeting at the
Legislative Office Building others are
appearing remotely through the zoom uh
App
application this is a public hearing on
bills referred to the house Judiciary
Committee it is possible that it would
be followed by an executive session
although it is not the it is not the
Chairman's intention to hold an
executive session
today please note that there is no
physical location for members of the
public to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court website
notice for this
meeting uh complies with house rules and
RSA
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call
271-3600 that's
271-3600 or email
HCS
l.st do.
Us in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
we do have staff uh assisting us today
our staff researcher Jennifer
4 please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call
vote and we'll begin the meeting by
taking roll call attendance and Mr clerk
would you like to call the
role thank you Mr chairman are you here
we can hear you oh you have to we have
to know uh where you are and who's with
you as
you announce your
attendance okay representative
mlan uh I'm here at the
L representative
Sylvia I am home alone in Belmont and uh
representative trer is looking for a
link I don't know if can send him link
again
representative welper is home in
straford his wife and dog are running
around the
house representative Alexander good
morning I'm here in gtown uh my
roommates could be in and out of the
room representative
rice yes I'm at home in my office in
gosh toown and the dog is staring me
down representative
silur represent representative
silur representative green yes I'm here
in my home in Hudson with my
wife representative Kelly hi I'm here at
home with my dog staring like Kim
said representative Tosh hello I'm just
here at home by myself representative
Trier are you on board with us
yet we'll come back
representative
Smith I'm here in Durham alone have you
moved U Mark page into the one of the
panelists you know what I sent him my
link and now he's coming up as me he was
out in the other room
[Laughter]
so Jennifer you could have a lot of
attendance representative Bur uh I am
here under my own link uh in West Milan
alone representative
Oregon um Horan also um our links didn't
work for some reason I hope
it's it's not explained but I see haran
as an attendee so please move
him uh what happened here oh I must have
hit a key uh representative Delorenzo oh
oh cut it out good morning I'm here in
my home office in New Market and my
husband will be in and out of the house
thank you I was can I can
I representative Oregon I'm sorry about
that I had the difficulty with the link
too I'm I've now been promoted to
panelists so I'm I'm here alone in my
home at
Durham the link that I provided to be a
panelist on the fourth didn't work so it
said the host was in another
meeting representative
Chase representative Chase has sent me a
message this is representative McBeth um
saying that she's having to reboot her
computer she she thinks she's having a
different technical issue but she'll be
coming on board shortly thank
you uh representative
Kenny I'm here in my apartment in Durham
um loone in my room but my roommates are
within the apartment thank
you excuse me representative Langley are
you with
us yes I am thank you um I'm here in
Manchester and my husband will be in and
out and thank you
Joe representative
McBeth thank you representative McBeth
is here in Portsmouth and her office
alone thank you representative
Paige here in exitor alone thank you
representative
Simpson hello I'm here in exiter I'm
alone now my sons and husband may come
through at some
point all right who do we have to go
back
to representative
silur representative tradier are you
on apparently not represent
Chase so I guess we'll have to uh wait
for these other people to get elevated
and then we'll consider them
attending with that we have like 17 or
18 I forget to count in attendance Mr
chairman thank you Mr
[Music]
clerk now uh we be prepared to go
forward and move forward with house
bills 622 and
625 hearing contemporaneously today
and I'll call upon the prime sponsor of
House Bill 622 representative Stapleton
to provide his
testimony thank you uh Mr chair uh and
the members of the Judiciary Committee
I'm Walt
Stapleton I'm U Sullivan County District
5 uh Claremont ward 3
representative and I am the prime
sponsor of HB
protecting na human life as a reasonable
and valid State
interest this bill steps away from
religious emotional and political
considerations and instead focuses on
the particulars of the Supreme Court
decision in Planned Parenthood versus
Casey of
1992 which superseded or overturned some
of the significant portions of Ro v Wade
the first trimester
standard and do versus Bol
Bolton uh the abortion post
viability both of
1973 for a viability principle relative
to gestational development when an
abortion may be
permitted given that this matter of
abortion is a highly charged and
divisive issue in our culture today
my bill is an attempt to utilize the
Supreme Court decision in
Casey to establish some common ground of
acceptability on both sides of the
issue and thereby restore some respect
we should have to the intrinsic value of
human life from early stages prior to
birth and acknowledge the state's
interest in protecting early life
enabling birth and growth into
productive citizenry endowed with those
other rights of Liberty property and
pursuit of happiness that we all enjoy
Arisen from the privilege of
Birthright the intent is to reduce if
not yet completely eliminate the
dichotomy we've had for the last 48
years between the right to life of the
pre-born and the lawful consent granted
for abortion under the
law just as Fair
disclosure I am a practicing catholic
christian who holds to the belief that
teaching and teachings that all human
life is sacred and in violate from the
moment of conception to the moment of
natural
death but this bill is separately
focused on the law as it stands today
without any reflection on its moral
validity the court wrestled with the
point at which abortion should be
acceptable or not and split in their
views on each of the five elements
challenged in the Pennsylvania law with
the Casey
case it was thought at the time that
Casey Would overturn
R but when they got right down to it
just as sudor and Kennedy flip-flo to
make a 5 to4
plurality and out of it all came three
essential
Holdings one women have the right to
have an abortion prior to
viability without undue burden from the
state two the state can restrict
abortion post viability if there are
bypass for life and
health
and three the state has a legitimate
interest from the outset of
pregnancy in protecting the health of
the woman and the life of the pre-born
child so why does the state have an
interest in this human life our
population growth has stalled and if it
weren't for immigration it would be in
Decline we're having trouble filling
jobs even before covid with Help Wanted
signs all over the
place and business owners complaining
about the quantity and even the quality
of the labor
pool and Social Security is forecast to
go bankrupt in what TW in what maybe
2034 or so
due to everl lasening contri
contributors and an increase in benefit
numbers and
amounts it should be no mystery why that
is contraception has been in full swing
for
decades and by the collective estimates
of the
CDC gut marker Institute and other
organizations that keep the
count America has aborted 62 million
unborns since
1973 we are now a population of 325
million people in America
so what we would have been without that
elimination maybe 400
million our national fertility rate by
rough measure under the total fertility
rate with the
TFR is that is at
1.73 and that's a 2018 figure children
per lifetime of a childbearing woman
in 1980 it was
1.84 replacement rate would be
2.08 according to a Pew research
study viability is
imprecise and while it only references
to the possible range of 22 to 28
weeks it respects and relies upon the
expertise and ethics of medical
profession
professionals to exercise their best
judgment comporting with their
hypocritic
oath termination of pregnancy is a
serious matter and some variability is
necessary in a caseby casee
context family and partner
decisions this bill recognizes the
importance of other relational affected
and counseling persons
to Aid such a weighty
decision but at the pregnant woman's own
selection an important component of the
Casey
decision how often do we seek counil
when making a big purchase or a major
life
decision deciding to terminate the life
of a child in the womb is no slight
matter and our standards of care and
concern
shouldn't let an individual be alone in
that
decision where council is sought or
necessary HP 622 addresses those
elements in the decision in
casing and should therefore be
considered ought to
pass thank you
and questions as you wish thank you
repres representative staple did you
submit that in writing I will submit
that in writing thank you okay are there
questions for representative
Stapleton
yes I heard a yes oh I'm sorry I thought
you were asking
me I I don't see any questions uh from
the committee and again thank you for
your testimony representative Stapleton
thank you Mr chair the primary sponsor
of House Bill
625 is representative fsel and we hear
from representative fulam
next good morning
morning uh thank you uh chairman Gordon
and the members of the committee for
giving me this opportunity to speak to
the fetal Life protection act um it is
kind of shameful that we are still
having to be here addressing this kind
of embarrassing lack of
restrictions whatsoever on abortions
performed in a mother's womb and to
enact moderate Common Sense hopefully
bipartisan prohibition on abortions
performed at or after the 24th week as
we sit here New Hampshire has a
republican
Trifecta however this bill will not
bring us into line with other Republican
Trifecta States what this will do is
bring us in line with other Democrat
Trifecta States uh such as Minnesota um
Washington and our neighbor Maine uh New
Hampshire and is described by Planned
Parenthood and many other pro-choice
organizations as one of the most
abortion friendly states in the nation
um our state has has only one single
just one substantive restriction on
abortion um we have an abortion on a a
procedure called intact dilation and
extraction of a viable fetus um in such
a procedure and I'm going to quote from
RSA
32933 the health care provider delivers
the entire fetal head outside the body
of the mother or in case of breach
presentation the fetal trunk pass a
native Naval sorry and kills the
partially delivered living
fetus
unquote in other words the only
abortions that this general court has
seen fit to prohibit are those in which
the abortion provider is preed prepared
to pierce the skull of a recognized
human
infant Pro prohibitions on abortions at
or after 24 weeks should be a bipartisan
measure roie Wade um the gold standard
for the pro-choice movement addresses
this particular um issue in roie way the
Supreme Court explicitly rejected I want
to make sure you hear the word rejected
the view that and I'm going to quote
again entitled to terminate her
pregnancy at whatever time in whatever
way and for whatever reason she alone
chooses and that's the end of the quote
I recognize oh so much I recognize that
is in this polarized political climate
the extreme view that Ro the Wade uh
rejected has ironically become kind of
the religious Creed for the pro-choice
movement and for many Democrats in
elected office the unfortunate fact that
if I had even introduced a 37-week ban I
would be surprised I would be pleasantly
surprised but I would be persu P
surprised if I persuaded a single
Democrat to support it yet um I do call
on the support of pro-life Republicans
moderate Republicans and those
Libertarians who recognize that a fetus
acquires rights at some point in its
development prior to birth after all
this bill is nothing more than the kind
of restriction contemplated as
permissible in row itself and I'd be
glad to take questions I just want to
remind you I'm a freshman legislator
this is my first hearing and I'm shaking
inside so be
gentle thank you for your testimony and
congratulations ation on your
first so are there questions for
representative
fulson yes representative mlan yeah uh
thank you Mr chair I have a couple of
quick questions question representative
fom um you mentioned that this bill is
going to bring us in line with other
states such as uh Minnesota and Maine
were you aware of any challenges in uh
those states to that law and if so how
do those challenges Fair
um you know what I am not sure of that
there is a lawyer who's going to be
testifying and I bet he has checked on
that so um feel free to ask them how
that
went just a quick followup for curiosity
um have you invited any out of state
groups to testify on the bill today uh
no we haven't um this is a bill that was
written here in New
Hampshire according to new hampsh sure
laws that is so important I do believe
that one of my co-sponsors has invited
someone uh yes um one of my co-sponsors
has invited an obri from the Charlotte
losier Institute but other than that I
don't even know of any outside groups um
that are testifying
today representative Horgan um yes just
a quick question and there's that phrase
Republican Trifecta what exactly are the
three legs of that Trifecta okay sorry
um it's the the fact that the
Republicans currently hold the Senate
the house and the governor's seat um and
so that's what I mean I'm sorry I by
using that expression on okay which I I
understand it has been that way since
December as I know all too well it's
kind of the plop a lot we've been
flip-flopping around since I which is my
seventh term but anyway
thanks okay any other questions for
representative
fulson seeing none thank you for your
testimony today
representative thank you very much for
listening okay as I indicated uh we're
going to uh hold our speakers to a three
minute time frame uh for speaking and
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
call out I'm off screen
what I'm going to do is name who I will
be calling a few questions and now
there's like aund witnesses that are
signed up to speak so they're just
representative
fome there's like 100 representative
fome on both
sides I don't know I don't get to see
the witness list your off
screen can you
hear
okay thank you that's better as I
started to say uh what I'm going to do
is call out five names the five
names uh are people who I will be
calling next and what I'd ask you to do
those five people if you are in fact out
there if you would just raise your hands
and then we can easily pick you up and
that will save us a lot of time as we go
forward okay uh the five people that
will be calling are
uh it's and do my best chopa Dera
vula that's
dropa Dera
vula Margaret
shuran Maris
Tolen Alia
Ana Sarah
Basco and Christina
Francis
and I would call upon Dr shopa Dera vula
first wow how am I supposed to deal with
that
you hello can you guys hear me yes we
can hear you
okay
all right um thank you all for allowing
me to be a part of your uh hearing
today can you guys hear an echo yes
we're hearing an
echo okay I'm gonna um try
again can you hear me now okay yes it's
better much better all right thank you
so much for your time today I'm um
really grateful to be in front of all of
you um esteemed representatives to got
some views about um HB
622 um I would like to keep this brief
for your time I do work as a physician
in OBGYN working alongside amazing
colleagues who are equally upset and
worried about the implic 622 on our
patients um we would like to start with
just the facts especially since HB 622
talks about protecting the life of the
mother and the life of The Unborn as uh
one of the representatives kindly shared
to develop a Workforce of productive and
to um uh
increased quality of life in New
Hampshire when people have an abortion
at later terms it's not for reasons that
they choose many times it's for women
who have experienced some of the worst
news of their life and finding out that
their baby has a fetal anomaly or
complications that threaten their life
or their um life as a mother these are
women and partners who have created
homes and cribs and dreams and um have
imagined a future for their child these
are not people who um have not not seen
themselves as parents already sometimes
abortions occur because these F
anomalies are incompatible with life as
in they are not going to be able to live
outside of the womb as in they cannot be
prisons for our society they will not be
able to survive and for that reason we
offer this as a way the the uh mother to
make a choice that probably rips her
heart open to have to under that late
term um the testing that you know
another bill that's coming up talks
about you know whether or not patients
are adequately informed is insulting in
many ways because the way in which we
talk to our patients is from our heart
we give them all the information have
already done the ultrasound that's how
we diagnose these anomalies we've done
the testing and we've talked about all
possible options and sometimes it isn't
an abortion that these patients have to
undergo they have to undergo a C-section
or even a vaginal delivery having to
undergo the process of Labor without
ever um holding their baby alive in
their hands and that is something that
is so devastating um I remember having a
patient of my own been trying for years
to achieve a pregnancy undergoing
treatments for fertility and praying for
a child she was herself a religious
person really attached to the idea of
becoming a mother um but when she found
out that her baby had what they call an
and seph or a lack of a forbrain um and
that the baby would not survive she
spoke to ICU pediatricians MFS doctors
about her chances for survival talked to
her chaplain talked to her family and
talked to us and we did our very best to
give her options I remember being in her
delivery room and watching her deliver
her um baby and having to hold her baby
as her partner in her cried and there
was not a single dry eye in the room
everyone's heart was broken for them the
fact that you are going to be punishing
people with this bill HP 622
criminalizing a decision that no one
ever wants to make is absolutely
egregious and it makes all of us who
work so hard for our patients feel that
we have do our job adequately that
somehow now our jobs are not being done
to the best of their abilities and that
is in fact so un these people have
chosen the colors in their baby's
bedrooms and yet now you're telling them
they're criminals for having to make a
choice no person no God no external
being would ever want another person so
I humbly please do not place any more
pain on my patients who've had to make
these choices and undergo these
harrowing experiences my patients
deserve their lawmaker respect and
understanding and the right to make
their own medical decisions that's best
for themselves their family and their
circumstances circumstances that are so
unique circumstances that one single
Bill cannot cover and cannot even fathom
the diversity of those circumstances so
I ask that we protect those who deserve
a safe access to Safe Care and a safe
abortion setting when unexpected events
occur that change their lives forever so
thank you for your time I'm here to take
any questions okay are there any
questions for Dr Dar
vula seeing none thank you for your
testimony
today sorry I'm trying to get back into
the audio so give me one second
hereid thank you very much for your
testimony Mr chairman uh the
representative Norman silver I'm sorry I
was in another hearing before another
committee I am here in my home office in
Guilford by myself with my
dog well welcome to
the thank you representative silver
thank
you Margaret uh actually uh the next
speaker would be Alia
Ana can you hear me we
can okay thank you members of the
committee in the the chair thank you for
letting me speak my name is AIA Ana I'm
a 21-year-old resident of the town of
hookit and I'm the president of students
for life at the University of New
Hampshire on behalf of the club members
and the exec board I strongly support
these bills house bill
2625 and House Bill
622 for far too long New Hampshire has
been one of the few states in the nation
that allow abortion at any point for any
reason with taxpayer
funding it is one out of three states in
the nation that has no statistics on
this procedure it doesn't have any
inspections on abortion facilities and
it is only one out a few states without
protections concerning pre-born
children these house bills seek only to
honor distinctions made in legal
precedent and in Planned Parenthood
versus Casey regarding
viability not only can babies feel pain
starting at 21 weeks but they can also
survive outside of the mother when
delivered or in other words are viable
at 24 weeks full disclosure I am a
Protestant Christian and I do believe
that life does begin at conception and
believe there should be no reason to
have an abort for any
reason but New Hampshire by passing this
bill passing these two bills excuse me
would be joining the majority of States
some de Democratic in placing some
restrictions on late term
abortions there will be absolutely no
new Criminal penalties on providers who
violate the law the bill will simply
apply the same class B penalties in
place for one late term abortion
for all lat term procedures and it only
applies to doctors who intentionally
violate the law not those who do it
accidentally and there will absolutely
be no criminal penalties for the mothers
who choose to have this
procedure Common Sense laws regarding
protecting pre-born children and their
mothers is a no-brainer so please
support House Bill 625 and 622
thank you thank you for your testimony
are there any questions from
Miss see none thank you uh the next
person we'll hear from is Dr Maris
Tolen hi can you hear me good okay hi my
name is Maris tooland I'm a resident
physician at Dartmouth Hitchcock and I'm
a resident of Lebanon New Hampshire as a
healthc care provider my mission is to
provide comprehensive
unb can you hear me you can okay
evidence-based information to my
patients and to their families and help
them to use that information to make
make the best medical decisions for
their health I specifically went into
Obstetrics and Gynecology because I want
to help women through Monumental
lifechanging experiences that includes
desired pregnancies and child birth but
that also includes challenging and life
um altering and devastating situations
like pregnancy loss abnormal fetal
diagnosis and Family Planning I'm here
today to join many of my colleagues in
opposing House Bill 622 and House Bill
625 there are many reasons that women
May seek to undergo an abortion
procedure and as a physician and also as
a woman I do feel strongly that women
should be able to make their own
personal and private healthare decisions
without politicians standing in that way
no matter where we live representative
Stapleton subm stated in his bill
submission that he recognizes the need
for case-by casee consideration for
individual needs and circumstances
however his proposed Bill negates just
that and it poses a health risk to the
women of our state these bills limit
access to life-saving procedures
abortion later in pregnancy may be
necessary when complications severely
compromise a woman's health
or her life and there these are
conditions that can also reduce um the
possibility of survival that includes
preclampsia infection premature rupture
of membranes placental abruption and
other conditions that can put women at
risk for extensive blood loss for stroke
for septic shock and lead to maternal
death we shouldn't wait for a medical
condition to worsen and become
life-threatening before offering
patients the option for an abortion at a
safer period of time in that
pregnancy the other thing I'd like to
mention is that these bills do have an
unintended
repercussions for healthc care providers
in our state it advertises to the
country that New Hampshire is not a
friendly environment for health care
providers
the country is already in a national
shortfall of primary care providers and
obstetrician and gynecologists AOG or
the American College of obstetrician and
gynecologists PR L projected a national
shortfall of OBGYNs of up to 22,000 by
the year 2050 and they estimated that
half of us counties lack a single OBGYN
what a better way to discourage the next
wave of healthc care providers from
coming to our state of New Hampshire
than threatening to charge them with a
felony for providing evidence-based Care
by punishing not only patients who seek
to have safe established and accepted
medical care but also by punishing their
providers you send a des Dean dangerous
message about access to healthcare this
bill will negatively impact all women of
New Hampshire your daughters your
sisters your mothers your friends who
seek out care for everyday health issues
for pregnancy for gynecologic care I
believe that both of these bills are bad
for New Hampshire and I really strongly
encourage you to oppose it I'd just also
like to point out that this bill is
opposed by many um state government
government bodies including the American
Medical Association and the New
Hampshire Medical Society thank you for
listening to me today I've written um
written testimony that I've submitted as
well thank you very much representative
silver did you have a question I do have
a question for the doctor uh could you
tell us whether at Dartmouth uh they
perform abortions on fetuses that are
gestational age of 24 weeks or
older um I I have not personally done
and I and I am I would have to defer um
that gestational age is an age at which
um at which few women um seek abortion
and so I am not sure at that particular
gestational age um whether or not that
happens it's exceedingly uncommon and
and um if it did my suspicion would be
that it would be in the case of uh a
fetus that did not have um an ability to
maintain its own life outside of the
womb Mr chair followup please yes you
may uh doctor have you ever performed an
abortion where the gestational age of
the aborted fetus was 24 weeks or
over no I have not thank
you thank you represent
Alexander um thank you Mr chair and
thank you doctor for taking my question
have you seen um based on other states a
dramatic and sustained decline in the
next gener generation of healthcare
providers um in the states that have um
the law in
place um I do not have the statistics to
necessarily look at that but I um I can
say that for myself um I I would I would
be nervous um going to and practicing in
a state that has very um strict
restrictions um on the care that I am
able to
provide
repres Alexander yes thank you Doctor
any other questions for the
doctor see none thank you very much for
your testimony today thank you for your
time next speaker is Sarah
vasal hello yeah hello we can hear you
great hi Mr chairman and committee
members thank you for the opportunity to
speak my name is Dr Sarah bascal and I'm
a board certified OBGYN at Women's
Wellness and Fertility Center here at
Catholic Medical Center and I've been
practicing in New Hampshire for the last
four years and I'm here in my individual
capacity to support House Bill 625 and
not to speak about the other
bill in my practice I follow women
throughout their reproductive years
including prenatally as well as
high-risk obstetrical care and as an
OBGYN I have the privilege of caring for
women and their unborn children through
some of the most in Intimate joyful and
heartbreaking moments of their
lives as an obstetrician um my role is
to assess the maternal as well as fetal
status in any pregnant patient
presenting for care in many hospitals
including my own when a woman presents
who is more than 20 weeks pregnant with
any obstetrical concern including
abdominal trauma
we evaluate her on labor and delivery
instead of the ER this allows us to
rapidly assess the mother and feedus
simultaneously and move quickly towards
an operative delivery if indicated if
she's more than 24 weeks pregnant the
present standard of care is to offer
full court press or complete obstetric
and neonatal
interventions for example if a mother is
bleeding heavily or the fetal heart rate
is low we would rapidly deliver V
C-section if indicated to save both the
mother's and the baby's life if the
mother is diagnosed with a
life-threatening infection we will
administer antibiotics and act to
deliver with subsequent resuscitation of
the newborn if greater than 24
weeks our neonatal intensive care units
in New Hampshire are well equipped to
care for these very pre-term infants and
can accept transfers from smaller
Community Hospitals who do not have
higher level
units thus an abortion ban at 24 weeks
is not a restriction on current medical
practice but rather supports the current
practice of full neonatal interventions
for neonates delivered at 24 weeks just
stational age or
greater finally this bill is not
intrusive or restrictive to The
Physician patient relationship it
appropriately allows the physician to
evaluate her patient for a current
medical emergency that could result in
significant health risk to the woman
this bill provides protection for all
fetal patients greater than 24 weeks
thank you and I'm happy to take
questions thank you are there any
questions for Dr
D see none thank you very much for your
testimony
today so um doctor did you submit that
in writing as
well
I will I will submit it thank you thank
you I need that answer from everybody
because I have to indicate that and I
can't tell unless they tell
me thank you for letting me know that Mr
clerk see if we can make sure that it
happens the next person to testify is
Margaret
shuran could she raise her hand yeah is
Margaret shuron
there don't see a raised
hand I don't see Margaret
Sheron uh Dr Christina
Francis I'm sorry
TR can you hear me I can hear you okay
all right great thank thank you Mr
chairman and esteemed committee members
I would like to thank you very much for
the opportunity to speak with you today
and I would like to thank representative
Mooney for her invitation to be here
today in support of the policy set forth
in HB 625 I'm not here to speak to any
other bills my name is Dr Christina
Francis I am a board certified OBGYN and
I have been in practice for 12 years I'm
also chair of the board of the American
Association of pro-life OBGYN and an
associate scholar with the Charlotte
loer in Institute I currently practice
as an obgy and hospitalist which means
that in addition to managing routine
labors and deliveries I also take care
of many women with high-risk medically
complex
pregnancies as an OBGYN I have the
unique Challenge and privilege to
simultaneously care for two patients
when I'm providing prenatal care
throughout the pregnancy I'm not only
monitoring the mother's health and
well-being but the fetal well-being as
well there are well accepted standards
of care relating to both patients from
the early earliest stages of the
pregnancy until delivery and the science
is clear that fetal human beings are
fully human and alive I care routinely
for patients who deliver pre-term
infants even as early as 23 weeks who
are then successfully cared for after
delivery because of amazing advancements
in the field of neonatology as well as
obstetrics infants born at 24 weeks now
have a 70 to 80% survival rate most of
them without significant impairments
when active resuscitation efforts are
done
these survival rates are increasing the
more evidence we have of the benefits of
active interventions for the neonates at
these gational ages in fact the
University of Iowa one of the leaders in
the US in regards to Nikki care for
premature infants recently published
their data showing that with a policy of
nearly Universal interventions for
infants born at 22 to 24 weeks survival
rates at 24 weeks approach
90% per the gut marcker Institute the
majority of women who have abortions in
the second trimester do so for the same
reasons as those in the first which are
largely socioeconomic reasons an
abortion ban at 24 weeks is not
intrusive into the physician patient
relationship but rather consistent with
current Medical Science in fact in a
joint statement from 2016 the American
College of OBGYN and the society for
Maternal Fetal Medicine recommended that
at 24 weeks all normal obstetric and
neonatal interventions be employed
adopting this policy would show that the
state of New cares about all of its
citizens especially its most
vulnerable this will not in any way
jeopardize the lives of women in fact
the mortality rate associated with
abortion increases by 38% for every week
Beyond eight weeks gestation and
abortion is done making abortions done
after 24 weeks significantly higher risk
for women in the rare circumstance in
which a woman's life is endangered by
pregnancy complications Beyond 24 weeks
she can be quickly delivered in fact
much more quickly than an abortion at
this gational age and both she and her
baby taken care of this is in complete
alignment with standard practiced by the
vast majority of
obgym in fact 85% of obgym do not
perform abortions at any gestational age
with exceedingly few performing them
beyond the first trimester especially
after viability this bill will not
dissuade OBGYN from practicing in your
state the policy of banning abortions
Beyond 24 weeks would acknowledge the
fact that infant born of this ational
age are viable pain capable human beings
deserving of the now standard medical
care that is available it's in no way in
truth on the relationship of a physician
with either of their
patients thank you Dr gonna ask you
thank you for allowing me to talk to you
thank you questions for Dr
Francis seeing none oh representative uh
Simpson has question oh sorry
representative Simpson go
ahead hello thank you Dr Francis I heard
you say that this wouldn't affect women
in our state and I wondered if you would
share with us where you practice if it's
not in New
Hampshire sure um I currently practice
in in Indiana and I was invited um due
to being an associate scholar of the
lure Institute as well as chair of the
board of of the American Association for
life of Representative Moody reached out
to me and invited me to
suby great thank you welcome
yeah thank you thank you any other
questions for Dr
Francis seeing none can I will submit my
I haven't submitted it yet but I will
submit my testimony and writing and it
it has um my sources cited as
well okay and you heard that
representative W coach she going I did
thank
you okay thank you the uh the next
people to testify this is a just a few
and again if you would raise your hands
uh Joshua Gordon no
relationship Carol
kitki George
Gonzalez Richard
Johnson and Hillary C
Cullen and I will call upon Joshua
Gordon attorney
Gordon hi I'm Joshua Gordon thank you
for hearing me this morning um that in
our founding documents of our country uh
Liberty is uh everywhere in the
declaration independence in our
Constitution and the Republican party is
the party of Liberty um and Liberty
means not restraining personal choices
of
citizens and the Republican Party my my
my party of Liberty um has this big fat
exception for reproductive health of of
women and just um uh my daughter's body
is not my business and it's not your
business these bills make mockery of
Liberty and Republican principles urge
you to vote against them thank you very
much thank you for your suin testimony
are there questions
for attorney Gordon
sing thank
you the next person uh to testify will
be George
Gonzalez see
George I don't see him on the list of
attendees
the
next the next person would be Richard
Johnson
hello hello hello Mr Johnson we can hear
you thank you members of the Judiciary
Committee my name is Richard Johnson I'm
a New Hampshire resident and hold a New
Hampshire medical license in support of
house spell 625 I submit this testimony
the two decisions Row versus Wade in
1973 and Casey versus Planned Parenthood
in 1992 the United States Supreme Court
affirmed three principles one women have
the right to abort a pre viable fetus
without undue interference from the
state two the state may restrict
abortion of the post viable petus and
thirdly the state has a legitimate
interest in protecting both the woman's
health and the life of the petus house
bill 625 does not violate any of these
rulings of the Supreme Court in addition
this bill does not open the gate for a
flood of legislation that would seek to
criminalize medical
procedures abortion is not a procedure
that cures a disease or except in the
rarest of occasions Saves a Life it is
not the procedure that is being
criminalized it is the result of the
procedure that makes it penus as OST
wrote in the Journal of medical ethics
in December 2018 quote it is the context
that makes a given procedure and
criminal events end quote that is the
abortion of a viable fetus purposefully
harming a patient makes any procedure
criminal taking the life of a viable
fetus a baby on its way to becoming a
member of our society is not close to a
procedure that removes a cancer
amputates a gangrenous foot or removes a
dise diseased
gallbladder this bill in no way
establishes a precedent to criminalize
the everyday procedures that are
performed to save and improve the lives
of the sick and the injured and as I
said it is not the procedure but the
result of the procedure that makes it a
class be felony you and the medical
profession do not need to fear that this
is a stepping stone to the
criminalization of medical procedures
this bill is simply following the
guidance to you by the Supreme Court to
protect the life of the viable fetus
thank you for allowing me to give this
testimony and I did submit it
online thank you very much for your
testimony today are there questions for
Mr
Johnson seeing none again thank you for
your testimony thank
you the next person would be Carol k
nitzki
Carol raise her hand if she's here yeah
Carol if you're there you need to raise
your hand so we can pick you
out let's
see next person would be Hillary
kill
good
morning good morning good morning okay
my name is Hillary Kil Cullen from
conquered New Hampshire I've been a
physician assistant for 42 years
practicing here in New Hampshire for
most of them when I first came to New
Hampshire the argument
pro-abortion was for a safe and rare
option for women facing a difficult
situation the option now allow ows for
terminating unborn children for any
reason at any stage or for no reason at
that for that
matter we medical professionals have
absolutely no ability whatsoever to
create
life but we do have the power to destroy
it of course destruction of life is
against all the we train and strive
for so have to twist the reality around
and come up with some explanation that
puts terminating unborn life on an equal
footing with Justice compassion and love
for
others and we do that by saying it's
none of our business it's between a
woman and her
provider our country today is full of
violence anger disrespect depression how
do we get here people are asking
probably in the same same way our hearts
and Minds went from being saddened and
resistant to killing The Unborn to
defending such acts with self-righteous
and ever expanding legislation thank you
and I have submitted my uh comments
online for your testimony are there any
questions see I have a question yeah
what kind of dog is
that
that's a that's a lab that we got
yesterday and unfortunately I just
really can't stay on mute for very
long thank you thank you very much thank
you for your testimony
today the next group of speakers will
be Elana
foren Jean
rusa Roy Den Bob
Dunn and and Chelsea
Gan and try
this and if you would all raise your
hand I just called your name so we know
where to find
you
and we'll
call upon all I don't necessarily see
her here Alana
foran Shez Mr chairman how am I supposed
to know who these people are
then Jean
Hara good morning thank you for um my
name is Jeanie haruska I'm the political
director for the American civil
liberties Union of New Hampshire and I
really appreciate the opportunity to
testify today in opposition to both HB
625 and HB 622 which would deny
Healthcare to people who need need it
viability is nearly impossible to
determine in utero it differs one
pregnancy to another and can differ
depending on the healthcare facility HB
625 would deny would defy science and
medicine by defining viability with an
arbitrary number and restricting
people's Access to Health Care based off
of it moreover HB 625 also has a very
limited exception that applies only to
the life and quote physical health of
the pregnant person this narrow
exception excludes people people who
become pregnant due to rape or incest
and the narrow exception excludes
abortion Services necessary for the
emotional or psychological health of the
pregnant person or other considerations
as determined by a patient and their
doctor for its part HB 622 imposes a
requirement that a pregnant person be
quote adequately informed without
defining what that means more alarming
is the Bill's requirement that a
pregnant person be quote open to the
counsel of her husband spousal partner
family or advisor this implies that a
patient is not only unable but is not
allowed to make their own decision
regarding their own health in
consultation with their doctor but
instead m al must also be counseled by
Family while many patients likely do
consult with their family and spouse it
is patronizing to require that they do
so by law I would beg this committee to
point to a problem in our state that
these bills solve medical decisions
later in pregnancies are never easy
which is why doctors and patients are
best positioned to weigh all the factors
and make the best decision they can the
government does not help by putting
those decisions under a microscope and
threatening criminal liability I
respectfully urge the members of this
committee to vote inexpedient to
legislate on both HB 625 and 622 thank
you and I'm happy to take questions
thank you for your testimony there
questions yes representative
Chase
I'm sorry I just missed where you were
from Jean thank you for that question
I'm based out of conquered and are you a
health care provider or just here for
yourself no I'm representing the
American civil liberties Union of New
Hampshire thank you I missed that thank
you very much that was
all any other
questions seeing none again thank you
for your testimony
today
next we call upon uh Bob
dun uh thank you Mr chair members of the
committee it's good to see all of you um
I'm looking forward to when we can all
see each other in person again um I'm
Bob Dunn I'm the director of the office
of public policy for the Roman Catholic
dasis of
Manchester and I'm speaking today uh in
support of House Bill
625 um as you probably know over the
years we've actively advocated on all
sorts of issues relating to life and
human dignity so we've supported repeal
of the death
penalty we've stood up for uh the rights
of immigrants we have uh sought
protections for victims of human
trafficking and we support this bill for
examp exactly the same
reasons as you consider what to do with
this bill um I'd like to ask you to
think about the question of how the
issue of abortion as controversial as it
is resonates in other areas
also if we want Society to respect and
value the child who is a
refugee with a child who is homeless
with a child who doesn't have access to
health care then we have to respect and
value the child in the womb as
well if Society decides that certain
ones of us can be treated as
Expendable we should not be surprised if
Society treats certain ones of us as
Expendable and so I ask you to vote in
favor of House Bill
625 thank
you thank you for your testimony any
questions for Mr
dun seeing none thanks for your
testimony the next person would be Roy
Deni I don't see a hand
rais
Chelsea
gaman hello good morning can you hear me
can hi thank you so much for taking your
time I really appreciate it I'm here
speaking on behalf of myself I'm a New
Hampshire resident uh I'm just here to
um support this bill HB
625 uh I am currently pregnant and I
support this bill I would like to boldly
state that any form of abortion is
murder there is forgiveness from God for
those who have aborted or performed an
abortion although his Amazing Grace does
not condone the act of abortion I would
like those here to consider that there
are many options for women who are
pregnant such as adoption foster care
Etc and although it would be ideal that
a baby remain with her own birth parents
if the circumstance and safety allow as
I support this bill I would like to even
challenge those here today to consider
that life begins at conception at just 5
weeks pregnant I went to get an
ultrasound and I saw the heartbeat of my
precious baby it was just the size of my
pinky fingernail I would like to ask
those present um that they would
consider passing a bill that would state
that whenever the baby's heartbeat is
found that abortion the murder of these
precious children would become
absolutely illegal thank you so much for
your time I certainly support this bill
and would again ask that you consider
even going further that at the moment
the heartbeat is detected that it would
be illegal to perform abortion please
consider this import important
life-saving action and thank you again
so much for your time and I'm willing to
answer any questions if
asked thank you for your testimony today
thank you sir any questions for miss
ganian seeing none again thank you for
your
time
the
next will be
Jane Dana
Pierce you a very good boy even messed
up Devon
ferelli Reverend
Heidi
Heath
and Elizabeth
Sida
and I will call upon Jane hay if Jane ha
is available if I just called okay um my
name's Jane heg and I'm a resident of
Manchester and I very much oppose both
of these
bills um I think that that we've reached
kind of a standoff in this country on
the subject of abortion and um I think
very much that it should be a choice
between a woman and her doctor when we
continue to do violence and by trying to
bring up these divisive issues over and
over and over again all we're saying is
that we don't trust women and we don't
trust their doctors to make a reasonable
and rational decision that takes into
account the health of the mother and the
wishes of the family and um we can't
always legislate that a woman consults
her family and um I just think that this
is endlessly bringing up these bills
that really aren't going to change the
way that anyone practices are are
divisive and I really wish that people
who bring them up would just stop I I
think it just reflects an obsession with
a small piece of Flesh that's the size
of a pinky
fingernail you know we all love babies I
have two beautiful children and I have
three beautiful grandchildren but we
need to have respect the needs and the
wishes of each family and each women
each woman to make choices on their own
with the consultation of their doctors
so thank thank you very
much thank you for your testimony I'll
ask I'll answer questions y are there
any questions for Miss representa silver
representative silver yes thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question would you Advocate abortion on
demand without any
restrictions um you know yeah I I would
actually because I think most women make
make take many things into consideration
before they actually consider having an
abortion it's not something that any
woman would take lightly thank
you any other
questions s thank you for your testimony
today and the next person to testify
will be Devon
farelli and I see he's on Deon is on the
list
can you hear me yes hi thank you very
much for your time my name is Devon fley
I'm a retired register nurse I live in
Rye my specialty was prenatal care and
child birth education and I support
House Bill
625 I would like to point out that in
tragic conditions that are incompatible
with life These are diagnosed far far
before 24
weeks that is when any medical decisions
need to be made at the time of
diagnosis in such tragic situations
delivering the Child Alive gives
families the opportunity to spend
precious time
together and The Grieving and recovery
process for the mother and her family
goes much much better when children are
delivered alive and families are given
the chance to spend this precious time
together thank you very much for your
time and I have submitted this in
writing
thank you for your succinct testimony
are there questions for miss
farelli seeing none again thank you for
your testimony
today next person is the Reverend uh
Heidi
Heath good morning can you hear me we
can thank you so much for your time this
morning I'm the Reverend Heidi
Carrington Heath I am an ordained
minister and also a former Hospital
chaplain who specialized in labor and
delivery and I'm speaking this morning
in opposition to this bill first and
foremost I believe it is the
responsibility of our legislators to
trust women to make the health care
decisions that are appropriate for them
with their medical providers um I want
to directly dispute the claim that all
diagnosis in this vein can be made prior
to 24 weeks that simply isn't true I
worked with multiple women in my time in
the hospital who received diagnosis
quite late in pregnancy and forcing them
to carry these pregnancies to term would
have been incredibly traumatizing and in
some cases really detrimental to their
health ultimately as a minister um and
as someone who has practiced in a
hospital setting I believe this bill to
be unconscious able and harmful to the
health of women thank you very
much your testimony other
questions rever
ke seeing n again thank you for your
testimony
today the next person to speak would be
Elizabeth
swera
oops hello good morning I'm right here
okay we can hear you okay thank you very
very much for taking my testimony it is
in writing but I want to say to each and
every one of you I thank your mothers
for being able to have you and I would
like to also say how much I appreciate
appreciate your
unbiased
um consideration in whether we are pro
um we are for this house
bill um
624 um and other Bill
625 I just wanted to make sure you know
that
um little
children don't have a voice except for
us and I really really would like to say
that this house bill reminds me of a
time when I witnessed a dog had been
trying to to reach dry ground he was
getting wearier by the moment because he
just couldn't get out he had jumped into
the Basin in the white mountain and it
had no way to get to safety the harder
the dog tried to swim out of his
surroundings the weaker he
became his master understanding the
situation was about to jump in and
rescue his beloved loved pet and then
someone suggested that we look for a
long stick or part of a branch that
could be placed under the dog's collar
and move him to
safety everyone there helped ultimately
the ideal stick with a small Hook was
found moments later and the dog was
rescued without his master jumping into
the Basin personally I believe God
performed a miracle that day simply put
the master and his beloved pet can be
compared with house bills 625 and this
committee your committee the master was
willing to put his life on the line for
his pet you the judicial committee is
charged to determine if the sanctity of
life is being protected and preserved
with The Unborn children because
ultimately all human beings have human
rights I wanted to present some facts
science proves at the moment of
consumption that the zot has a complete
and unique set of 46 chromosomes 23 from
Mom 23 from Dad which is the entire
genetic
blueprint on a in a suitable environment
and nutrition are all that this little
zot needs to develop throughout the
different stages of human life you see
science proves that at six days old the
embryo the blast of scy attaches to the
mother's uterus wall in 17 days the
blood cells develop in 19 days the eyes
start develop and in 20 days the
foundation of the nervous system is laid
and just one more there's a lot more but
between 18 and 21 days the heart begins
to
beat science may I just say um in
closing in closing three minutes so okay
in closing the ultrasound is a wonderful
way to show the mother to be what a gift
she has been given by God I pray that
you all make the decision to protect and
be the voice of the unbo and child thank
you very much thank you for your
testimony
today and the next speaker would be oh
are there any questions for Miss
Sher seeing none the next speaker would
be
Pi hello can you hear me you can okay uh
hi my name is Dr Dana Pierce and I live
in Yarmouth Maine so yes my story is
that of a mayor but if these abortion P
banss are passed in New Hampshire my
story could easily be that of any
Granite State woman complications and
pregnancies don't stop at Borders I am a
wife a mother of two living children and
a veterinarian I'm a Morehead Kane
scholar and a world champion rower but I
am also someone who has had an abortion
later in pregnancy on January 25th 2019
I was 32 weeks pregnant with my son
Cameron that morning my husband and I
along with our three-year-old daughter
went to what we expected to be a routine
ultrasound in a normal pregnancy but
that's when we found out that Cameron
had lethal skeletal dysplasia the result
of a random denovo or new rare genetic
mutation that occurs during sper sperm
development and it's lethal because
babies with this condition cannot
breathe outside the womb their rib cages
are too small Cameron's femur was also
broken and there was evidence of
multiple other healed
fractures in short Cameron was actively
suffering and faced death by Suffocation
if he managed to make it to turn and
survive
delivery I still cannot really put into
words the int intensity of Anguish and
grief that my husband and I felt in
those moments and in the days and weeks
that followed but I must strongly
emphasize that my thoughts were that I
would not let my son suffer any longer
than he already had unfortunately our
grief was then com compounded by the
limits on abortion light rights in Maine
and in our country those restrictions
meant that we had to fly across the
country and pay $25,000 in cash in order
to end our son's suffer
uing and while I was incredibly
fortunate to be able to afford the cost
of travel missed work lodging and the
fee for the abortion itself the majority
of women in my situation in this country
would not have been so lucky bands and
limits on abortion later in pregnancy
add exponentially to Mother's grief and
suffering we should instead be making
laws to ensure that women facing
situations like mine are guaranteed safe
Compassionate Care and support
abortion for any reason is a deeply
personal decision and should not have
anyone involved other than the pregnant
woman her medical team and any others
that she chooses to advise her please
join me in trusting and empowering women
to make ethical loving decisions for
their own bodies and families please
oppose House Bill 622 and House Bill 625
thank you I have submitted this
testimony in writing uh a more complete
version but I'm happy to answer any
questions now thank you for your
testimony are there any questions for
Miss
Pierce seeing that again thank you for
your testimony today thank you for
having
me I think at at this point in time uh
it it's 10:22 I guess give everybody a
10 10 minute break why don't we take a
10-minute break and so that everybody
have a chance for a short break and
we'll come back and finish the testimony
this
morning thank
you who can I
see so I would really like to have uh a
list of the
speakers that you have I know in front
of you with their name
appropriately spelled
Etc so that I can uh fix this up in the
minutes I mean it's really difficult for
me to figure out I mean Dana Pierce
wasn't too hard I I think uh we'll ask
Gen 4 to send you a list of the
speakers that would be very helpful
thank you I have a related I have a
related question um many people refer to
written testimony and of course I'm
drowning in emails so who
is it uh represent Ware is it Jen or who
who's going to be responsible for you
know uh capturing all these uh emails I
guess most of them being sent to the
house Judiciary account but I don't know
if anybody gets that inside the actual
members of the committee like how do we
who whose job is going to be to like
actually determine what goes in which
Bill file and then hopefully make the
bill files available at some point so
people can review them so they put on
the thing whether they want it to be in
the record and that well they do and
they don't
well they're supposed to so if they do
and it goes to the email address that is
on the link to sign up then that goes to
house committee Services too and they
put it in the record so so you're right
kimoy that for those people that put
those the magic words I guess I want to
put it into their uh Communications with
the committee I didn't realize there
were two of us looking at that so that's
good yeah but I I will tell you right
now that um I have done my best to
identify keep them
all right if the people submit a longw
written testimony then most often I make
separate files for them where often I do
but often I don't and I have a single
file right now that's 18 pages long I
have over a 100 emails still to deal
with for these bills well all these Pro
lifee bills I'm just asking I submitted
testimony a number of bills like there's
one today that I submitt a written
testimony for just want to make sure the
bill file so people can take a look at
it later because these Bill files too
are also going to become a lot more
available because of the changes we made
last summer so before everything was in
this files will be a a judici Nancy Cass
set's desk and then it would wander up
to the fourth floor and like really for
a couple of years they weren't really
easily accessible to anyone unless you
actually knew like who to go find at the
lob at asked whereas now these things
are going to be probably online more
quickly so going to be a little bit more
so some of that's at the Judgment of the
Court
yeah and some of it is more or less set
in practice where people ask to be part
of the permanent record or actually
testify okay so he should actually like
say the magic words if they can to make
sure it's preserved I don't
think I I got letter from HCS because
I've been just copying all my emails
through various committees just because
I had that concern like I don't really
know what the clerk going to do or like
who else is doing
it anyway well thanks myself right now I
don't know what the Court's going to do
either because I thought I could handle
this if we'd only get a hundred or so
emails but right now I have I think it's
three screens full yeah of emails to
deal with and and most of the people who
testified have already dealt with there
yeah thanks yeah it's a terrible it's a
thankless job and so anyway we'll see
you in a few
minutes
good morning Mr
chair good morning representative charia
this is representative Char I want to
apologize for my delay in entering this
meeting this morning but I have um got
in soon after it started I am at home in
my home office I do have three children
in the house I just wanted you to be
aware of that okay thank thank you very
much thank you
sir
minutes you're a good boy you have good
boy yes
yes scw
up
oh out at
10 I had to
call
good morning
everyone I'll call this meeting of the
house Judiciary Committee back to order
we are still here he in house bills 622
and
625 and the next list of speakers
is Sophia bionda
Leo Melinda
Chen Katherine Glenn
Foster Michael King and Peter
Kip and uh if those people would raise
their hands so will know where to find
them out there that would be appreciated
and I'll call upon first Sophia
beon do
Leo to
testify hear
me
hello can you hear me uh you're you're
not very loud if you could speak
up can you hear me better now yes all
right okay um thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee for dating my
testimony today my name is Sophia Biondo
I'm 14 I live in Manchester and I'm
speaking today on behalf of the New
Hampshire High School Democrats in
opposition to HB
625 before I start I would like to state
that this testimony has been shortened
in the interest of time um but a longer
version should have been emailed to the
committee which contains more
information um that said the nhhs is
opposed to HB 625 because this bill not
only fundamentally violates women's
reproductive freedom and autonomy but
also Al harms Women's Health directly
and adds unnecessary stress to
healthcare providers First of all only
slightly more than 1% of abortions are
performed at 21 weeks or later there are
several reasons why women obtain later
abortions that range from difficulties
finding a provider raising money for the
procedure and transportation costs
obtaining health insurance coverage to
health complications and fetal
abnormalities that are diagnosed late in
pregnancy this bill would only add
further delay and make it harder for
women to get in abortion when they need
to using gational age as a legal cut off
for abortion care is also problematic
babies are rarely delivered on schedule
and viability should be determined on a
case-by Case basic by medical case-by
case basis by medical professionals and
not
politicians the bill also cites that a
fetus is able to feel pain by 20 weeks
but that is a highly controversial
subject within the medical field in fact
several Studies have shown that a fetus
only develops the corticol function
required for perception of pain around
29 to 30 weeks of pregnancy flinching
back from a stimulus actually does not
mean that a fetus feels pain as a same
reaction can be evoked by
non but the anesthetics and Fetal
surgery is actually for the purpose of
reducing movement and preventing
hormonal responses not to stop pain thus
the claim that a fetus fetus would feel
pain after 20 weeks is unproven and
cannot be used to promote the
bill furthermore there's an overwhelming
amount of evidence that the vast
majority of women do not regret having
abortions on the contrary The Landmark
turnaway study says that women who were
denied abortions experience experienced
a wide range of detrimental effects on
their well-being they reported lower
self-esteem higher anxiety and ongoing
exposure to intimate partner violence as
well as being being more likely to
experience serious complications
associated with the later stages of
pregnancy such as eclampsia and death
women who were denied abortion also
experience poor maternal bonding with
their new children moreover women who
were denied abortion care have a higher
rate of unemployment and are more likely
to be impoverished even years after the
pregnancy this is why women in
low-income communities and women of
color would be so disproportionately
affected by this bill as the economic
pressures are strongest for them the
Bill's definition of medical emergencies
is also incredibly narrow it does not
take into account circumstances like
rape and incest and fetal abnormalities
diagnosed late in pregnancy that will be
factored into this decision and it says
nothing of psychological Health the
effect on women's health goes far beyond
what is defined in this bill requiring
providers to report abortions also adds
unnecessary stress to the provider who
should only be concerned with the best
interest of the patient having these
decisions under scrutiny by a third
party would add additional pressure onto
the provider without any medical benefit
to the patient in conclusion the
evidence is abundant that denying late
abortion care can be incredibly
dangerous and detrimental to a woman's
health and we need to give women
autonomy over their bodies and Leal
decisions to be between them and their
medical providers therefore I urge the
committee to vote against HB
68 thank you for your testimony are
there any
questions seeing none again thank you
again for your testimony
today the next p person to speak will be
Katherine Glenn
Foster
I'm Katherine Glenn Foster a
constitutional attorney mother and
post-abortive woman I serve as president
and CEO of Americans United for Life
founded in 1971 to advance the human
right to life in culture law and policy
I support HB 625 the fetal Life
protection act this bill furthers New
Hampshire's legitimate interest in
protecting maternal Health preventing
fetal pain and affirming life HB 625
sets a clear standard for providers
First later term abortions carry high
risks we know now what the justices did
not know in
1973 abortion harms women and that risk
increases substantially with gestational
age that's the strongest risk factor for
abortion related mortality a woman
seeking an abortion at 20 weeks is 35
times more likely to die than in the
first trimester at 21 weeks or more she
is 91 times more likely to die later
abortions also pose a significantly
increased risk for maternal Health
immediate complications affect 10% of
women undergoing abortion and include
blood clots Hemorrhage incomplete
abortions infection and injury to the
cervix and other organs 20% of these
complications are life-threatening
abortion industry studies show most
later abortions more than 10,000 per
year are performed for the same reasons
as in the first trimester Financial
concerns relationship issues and not
feeling prepared for pregnancy all areas
where as a nation and in our communities
we must come alongside women and girls
to offer support resources and holistic
care and I have ex extensively examined
the selection biased problems of the
turnaway study suffice to say that
researchers did not hear from the women
whose voices most needed to be heard
second New Hampshire has a legitimate
interest in preventing fetal pain
current New Hampshire law does not
protect children from elective abortion
when they may feel pain Warren Hearn of
Colorado one of the only doctors in the
US to perform abortions after 30 weeks
estimates that only a third of the late
term abortions he performs are for
significant fetal health issues this
bill protects the remaining 70% of
children from elective abortion
thousands every year Nationwide a child
in the womb can experience pain by at
least 20 weeks post Fertilization in
2019 scientists found evidence of fetal
pain as early is 12 weeks gestation it
is well within legitimate State
interests to minimize fetal pain and
finally HB 625 is constitutional from
the beginning the Supreme Court has
explicitly limited the right to abortion
expressing state legitimate interests in
ensuring maximum safety for the patient
like any other medical procedure in row
and in showing concern in protecting the
health of the woman Casey and Gonzalez V
carard per Casey a woman has some
freedom to terminate her pregnancy but
that Liberty is not unlimited states can
protect Women's Health from the earliest
stages of pregnancy and many do at least
24 states have an enforcable limitation
at 24 weeks LMP or earlier protecting
both mother and child the medical basis
for hp62 supports its constitutionality
I strongly encourage this committee to
protect maternal health and prevent
fetal Pain by voting in favor of HB 625
the fetal Life protection act thank you
thank you for your testimony today
representative Horgan did you have a
question uh yes yes thank you very much
Mr chair thank you very much M Glenn
Foster I just wondering are you speaking
simply as a supporter of these two bills
the head of organization that supports
more you or your organization have any
role in uh crafting either of these two
pieces of legislation and are they
similar to any sample legislation that
you may have disseminated to supporters
of your cause
thanks thank you for your question um
yes so I am speaking in support of HB
625 we did not have a role in crafting
this
legislation okay and what about you
support HB 622 or what's your no no no
I'm here to support HB 625 okay not the
other one
thanks
representative hi thank you for your
testimony Attorney Glenn Foster I am uh
wondering if you practice in New
Hampshire uh and if not um in what state
you
practice yes I'm licensed to practice
law in Virginia and DC as well as um
certain federal courts and part of the
role of my organization is to compare
the laws in different states when it
comes to bioethical issues and so we um
we often come to testify on the
different states and what the the
different bills are and the different
laws are in States Across the Nation so
that state legislators and lawmakers can
compare uh how their state would um
would compare to other states
Nationwide thank you any other questions
over here yes representative mlan yes
thank you Mr chair and and thank you for
taking my question so you mentioned that
the bill is constitutional and that um
It lines up the 24 weeks lines up with
bills in many other states um we heard
about Minnesota and Maine could you tell
us some of these other states and has it
been tested in the courts in any of
those other
states yes so at least 24 states do have
an enforceable limitation which means
that uh that it has not been overturned
or uh or in any way mooded in those
other states um if you're interested I
can get you a list of all of those
States I can send that over to the
committee I would appreciate that very
much thank you certainly
absolutely and they are in fact listed
in my written testimony as well but I
can send it again if that would be
helpful that would be helpful thank you
any other
questions seeing none again thank you
for your testimony today thank
you
would be Michael
King is Michael King
available I don't see a hand up for
Michael
King uh Mr chair there was a
Massachusetts Family Institute that
lowered their hand and raised it again
it might be um that Witness
you want me
to go
ahead thank you my name is uh Michael
King and I'm actually speaking as a
resident of New Hampshire um I recently
moved from Massachusetts uh to New
Hampshire uh thinking that I would be
moving into a state that had um you know
more conservative laws especially when
it comes to the sanct city of Life uh to
find out that for far too long New
Hampshire has been one of the only a few
US states that provides virtually no
protection for unborn children uh we are
even barred from knowing how many
abortions occur in the state and
currently abortions are legal
unrestricted and unregulated throughout
40 weeks of
pregnancy um I've already submitted my
testimony to the judicial committee uh
but I really just want to make one
simple Point um the only restriction New
Hampshire places on abortions is
prohibiting a single procedure uh which
is a partial birth abortion where a
living child is partially delivered
before being uh eliminated but this
arbitrary law only bans one specific
procedure so viable infants may still be
legally aborted at any time using other
procedures such as dismembering the
infant in the womb and REM removing them
piece by piece so to change that we must
act by passing
HB 625 so I just want to make that clear
that if we have a partial birth abortion
where the baby comes out alive then that
baby is as I understand it protected in
New Hampshire but if we dismember the
baby while in utero there is no
protection for that particular baby so
clearly we need some improvement to the
law and I hope uh you will consider that
and vote in report of HB
625 thank you for your testimony and are
there questions for Mr
King seeing none thank you thank you
again next person is Melinda
Chen is Melinda
available and I don't see Melinda on our
list of
attendees that being the case call upon
Peter
kipr oh y it's right
there hello yes we can hear you okay
thank you I would like to thank the
chair and the Judiciary Committee
members my name is Dr pet kiprop I'm a
family medicine provider who also does
obstetrics I've lived here in Hampshire
and practice for the last 12
years I would like to testify in support
of HB
625 I think this is a very reasonable
bill in support of FAL life we know that
after 24 weeks the survival rate of the
newborn
uh FS outside the womb of its mother is
significantly high as compared to any
time before that
period hence I think the reason why we
should support this
bill I distinctively remember around 8
years ago I was involved in a care of a
patient who had to be delivered at 25
weeks due to severe complications of her
pregnancy a newborn baby girl was
delivered who had to spent a long time
in the neonatal Care Unit but eventually
she got discharged from there and now
she's thriving both academically and
physic physically honorable members the
lives of these children will depend on
how you vote for this Bill thank you I
will submit my presentation to the
committee also thank
you thank you for your testimony are
there any questions
seeing none again thank
you uh the next group of people to
testify will be Shannon
McGinley Tanya
McIntyre Kayla
Montgomery Jessica
Morgan and Patrice Meyers if if I just
called your name if you could raise your
hands on the zoom so we can see you that
would be helpful
and I see we have Shannon McGinley you
can testify Miss McGinley great thank
you I appreciate you giving me the time
to testify my name is Shannon McGinley
and I live in Bedford New Hampshire and
I'm testifying to ask you to support HB
625 before my prepared testimony I just
want to share that my heart goes out to
Dana pierce the mother from Maine who
testified earlier as as well as her son
Cameron um my matron of honor in my
wedding Lorraine had a daughter Cecilia
with the same lethal skeletal mutation
baby Cecilia's condition was diagnosed
at the routine 20 weeks gational age 32
weeks is not normally considered the
gational age for a routine ultrasound
baby Cecilia's father is actually the
head of OBGYN department at a hospital
in New York Lorraine carried the baby
Cecilia to term the family held her
including her brothers and photos were
taken and she was actually baptized
before she passed away a few hours after
her birth like what was described about
Cameron Cecilia died once she had to
breathe with her own lungs because of
the pressure from the ribs I attended
the funeral and it was a beautiful death
with love all around for
Cecilia now my experience doctors can
misdiagnose in 2015 here in New
Hampshire at my routine 18we Ultrasound
with my last pregnancy a concern was
raised about the develop development of
my son Aiden days later I was sent for a
level two ultrasound there he was
diagnosed with a developmental anomaly
that although not life-threatening it
proper if properly managed with lifelong
medication he would have a physical
deformation The Physician gave us
various options including terminating
the pregnancy or abortion is another way
to put it my husband and I we chose to
pursue a second opinion and went to
Boston Children's Hospital for
additional testing a team of doctors
geneticists endocrinologists urologists
among others consulted with each other
they even met with us and determined
that we had a totally normal healthy
baby boy they didn't understand the
reason behind the diagnosis from the
doctor associated with a well-known
hospital here in New Hampshire we of
course wouldn't know for sure if he was
normal until he was born and sure enough
he was totally normal not a single thing
was wrong with them doctors are human so
they make mistakes too I wonder what
would have happened to Aiden if he had
been carried by a different mother who
would have sought out who would not have
sought out necessarily A cumbersome and
expensive second option would he have
been the victim of a therapeutic
abortion I'm grateful that we have Aiden
and so are his four brothers who dote on
him thank you committee for taking the
time to hear my testimony and I welcome
questions if you
desire thank you Miss McGinley are there
any questions from M
McGinley seeing none again thank thank
you for your testimony
today the next person to
testify would be Kayla
montgomer good morning honorable members
of the House Judiciary Committee my name
is Kayla Montgomery I'm the director of
public affairs for Plan paren and New
Hampshire action fund and plan parent of
Northern New England and we oppose both
both house bill to 625 and 622 and I
have submitted written testimony I'd
like to begin by reminding the committee
that there is no no one-sized fits-all
process when it comes to deciding if
when or how you choose to start a family
and there is no one-size fits-all
pregnancy either any doctor can tell you
every pregnancy is different and anyone
who has experienced multiple pregnancies
can confirm that these experience vastly
differ each time I personally have been
pregnant three times and each time was
very different with bills like this with
arbitrary band and abortion simply can't
account for every situation because
pregnancies are not predictable each
pregnancy and each circumstance is
unique and that's why when people making
personal medical decisions one size fits
all laws like this just don't work
families and medical providers need to
be able to make the best decisions in
each circumstance and not be bound by a
single law or policy families involved
in these unique circumstances deserve
our compassion and our support not our
judgment and certainly not government
interference bills like these politicize
a very complex situation at the expense
of both truth and compassion
the bottom line is people must have the
freedom and privacy to make decisions
about their pregnancy and consultation
with their doctor the state of New
Hampshire should not be in the business
of policing individual personal medical
decisions and finally today I want to
share Kelly's story she lives in conquer
and a few years ago she was pregnant
with her second child she found out
later in pregnancy that her son had a
fatal diagnosis and he would likely not
survive birth she couldn't be here today
so I wanted to just deliver some of her
story these are her words quote we had
to make the most difficult Choice a
parent could make we thought about what
would be the best kindest thing to do
for our child we decided to terminate
because it was the kindest decision to
do for our son our daughter and US
terminating for medical reasons was the
most difficult heart-wrenching decision
I've ever had to make in my life I knew
in that moment how lucky I was to have
safe local medical care and the ability
to choose what would be done to me I
didn't have to go out of state to get
the care I needed when it was over I
hurt like any other parent would after
losing a child each person is different
each pregnancy is different and there is
no one- siiz fitell solution it is
critically important for women to focus
on the decision that is right for her
life her baby's life her family's life
and not have to worry about state laws
that don't take into account complex
medical decisions end quote thank you
for your time today and I respectfully
urge you to itl both 625 and 622 thank
you thank you very much are there any
questions for M mon
seean again thank you for your testimony
today is Tanya
McIntyre
here do not see a raised
hand how about Jessica
Morgan again I do not see raised
hand
Patrice
Meyers okay the next group of speakers
will
be Ian
hya Neil
La
kelly9 Damen
Olen if they could raise their hands
that would be helpful
and I'll call upon Ian
huya good morning Mr chairman can you
hear me we
can my name is Ian huitt I'm general
counsel at Cornerstone which is a
Christian advocacy group here in New
Hampshire and you all have my written
testimony but I think it probably be
more productive if I responded to some
of the arguments we've heard against 625
this morning and I am only here to speak
this morning on House Bill
625 I was struck by the claim that this
bill would be unfriendly to Medical
practice and would frighten Physicians
away from New Hampshire as being a
medically unfriendly State I think the
clearest illustration of that not being
the case is Massachusetts until very
recently in Massachusetts most abortions
at or after 24 weeks were felony crimes
and Massachusetts had a health exception
but it was a narrowly Frank clearly
defined Health exception for serious
risk of grave bodily harm but in just
December the Massachusetts Medical
Society planed Parenthood action and
other groups successfully fought to
repeal those laws and legalize abortion
at any time in Massachusetts after 24
weeks I think most of us know
Massachusetts was not before December a
desert of Medical Practice US News
actually ranks Massachusetts the second
best in the nation in Act access to
Quality healthare and I don't think that
came out of nowhere in December when
they legalized abortion up to birth I
was particularly struck by the claim
that 24 weeks is just an arbitrary
number and this is interesting because
in 2018 there was an attempt to
introduce a viability Bill and one of
the main objections from the minority
committee report of this committee and
you can see this footnoted in my written
testimony was that viability was too
subjective a standard viability varies
from case to Case and it didn't provide
a clear rule of law now of course we're
hearing that a 24-week line is too
arbitrary and I think we can all
candidly admit at this point the actual
objection is not to vagueness or to
arbitrariness but to just any
restriction whatsoever on abortion prior
to birth which I think the data shows is
not consistent with the values of the
majority of people in New Hampshire both
row and Casey affirmed as one of their
Central premises that pregnancy is
different from other situations
involving privacy because a woman
carries a fetus and at some point in
time the state has legitimate interest
in protecting fetal life I don't think
in any of the critical testimony we've
heard today has that interest even been
acknowledged the interest in fetal life
isn't being balanced against other
interests it's being simply disappeared
and that's because the organizations
critical of 625 in fact don't recognize
the holding of row and Casey this bill
does and in fact it's more modest than
those cases in what it prohibits it is
not a piece of Flesh the size of a pinky
this is a recognizable human infant that
can be delivered as you've heard from Dr
basl and I think Dr Ki Rock and right
now in New Hampshire that infant has no
legal protections whatsoever under our
criminal law and I'm happy to answer any
questions thank you very much are there
any questions
Mr
huitt saying none again thank you for
your testimony today thank
you next call upon Neil
law is Neil law out
there I do not see him on the list of
attendees Kelly n
good morning can you hear me we
can great thank you for your attention
and the opportunity to share my
testimony in support of HB
625 regarding the protection of fetal
life my name is Kelly Nine I am 29 years
old I lived in Washington DC for The
Last 5 Years before moving back to New
Hampshire this summer where I was raised
during my time in one of the nation's
most Progressive cities I received my
MBA from Georgetown University and now
work for a leading technology company
company all St statistical data
including my being a woman suggests I
should be here today advocating against
this bill claiming my right to privacy
my right to do what I please with my
body and my Reproductive Rights but I'm
not here to do that I'm here to do the
opposite the arguments for abortive
rights get more sophisticated and
complex with time this alone should
cause us to pause because the truth is
always simple yes the application of
Truth does require immense wisdom and
discernment but the principles are
always simple and we cannot deviate from
them and still expect Society to
flourish today the simple truth is that
life in the womb is just that life and
life is always precious and worthy of
protection HB 625 protects the precious
life of both the pre-born and the
mother one particular argument in favor
of abortive rights after 24 weeks is
over fetal anomalies this argument
requires the belief that life is only
worth living if it will be free from
suffering suffering for a child who has
the possibility of a disability and
suffering for the parent whose own life
could be greatly impact Ed by a disabled
child well as the proud older sister of
a brother with immense cognitive and
physical disabilities I fully disagree
with this premise the truth is we all
inconvenience each other and there is
only one possible life for all of us a
hard life we all suffer life unfolds
unexpectedly for all of us but it can
still be beautiful if we realize another
simple truth that life is meant to be
lived s sacrificially for others though
I'm not here to claim rights for myself
my parents have beautifully lived out
their conviction that life is well-lived
and full of joy when you stay lock step
with the simple truth that life is
precious and worthy of protection no
matter the personal
sacrifice I envy your position and your
ability to stand as Protectors of the
simple truth with your vote standing for
life in the womb I fully support hb6 and
implore you to do the same I've
submitted my written testimony and I'm
happy to take any
questions thank you Miss n are there any
questions from Miss
n seeing none again thank you for your
testimony
today and do we have a Daman
Olen again I do not see Daman Olsen on
our list of attende
the
U that actually is the complete list of
those who pre-registered to speak here
today on 622 and
625 there are there is a hand up and a
couple of hands up actually one appears
to be from state representative Maria
Perez and represent Perez do you wish to
testify um yes okay yes thank you for
the opportunity to testify this morning
against Bill 622 and
625 okay you may test you may go for go
ahead and testify thank
you um I'm here as
um not as a state representative but I'm
here as a victim of a sexual
assault I was
abused by my own father I was abused
by my one of my
brother-in-laws and to be
honest when someone try to tell me what
is right and what is wrong for my body
it's a victim and a sexual
assault I don't think it's right for
someone to told me that
if I get pregant because
and in this I don't have the right to
have an
abortion a lot of times especially in my
culture people don't know the right and
a lot of times they don't know they
don't they don't speak the language so
we don't know exactly our right and
wrong and I would love and I asking you
can you
please do not pass these two laws cuz to
be honest if
as a victim of sexual assault I should
have the right to decide what what is
right in what is wrong for my
body okay thank you very much and I will
not take any questions thank you thank
you
and the next person I see who has their
hand up is uh Jason
Hennessy thank you can you hear me again
great uh honor honorary members of the
committee uh thank you for your patience
my name is Jason Hennessy I'm a resident
of mher New Hampshire and the president
of New Hampshire right to life I'm here
to speak in favor of both HB 622 as well
as HB
625 um so I would like to ask the
committee members to consider two things
um as they're contemplating this two
questions the first one is who is a
person and the second one is what
protections to do those people
deserve um and I'd like to submit to you
that most of the the great human
atrocities that you can think of happen
when a society gets one or both of these
wrong so on the question of who is a
person um some some other questions to
ask yourself should that should that
definition depend on someone else's
Choice uh should that be based on a
crime committed before they conceived or
whether someone thinks that their life
is worth
living the the gooder Institute says
that 43 St 43 states have some
restriction on um on on abortion up up
into uh lat term viability bands so in
other words 86% of States agree that
there should be some sort of restriction
um and and the and the the number of
weeks that are proposed in HB 625
reflects the the the very the very
latest end of that 24 weeks is the very
is the very latest of that and so I'd
like to speak in support of this of
these bills and I would love to take any
questions you might
have very much Mr Hennessy are there any
questions for Mr
henness seeing none again thank you
again for your testimony thank you and
Elliot
axelman
hi can you hear me now you can excellent
thank you very much for letting me speak
Mr chair my name is Elliot axelman I
live in hooks at New Hampshire I'm happy
to be here I'm a critical care and
flight certified paramedic and EMS
educator I'm speaking today on behalf of
myself and not any organization
um speaking in support of houseal 622
and
625 as a paramedic I've been in Ems for
about uh 10 years now since 2011 pretty
much we determine life on a heartbeat
essentially we I can declare death when
I work cardiac arrests I can declare a
time of death and that's based on
heartbeat when there's no heartbeat we
generally resuscitate and when we feel
that there no longer is any chance of
resuscitating the heartbeat and there's
been no heartbeat for 10 20 30 minutes
depending on the rest of the metrics
like entitle CO2 and other metrics uh we
can then ter we declare death in a time
of death so heartbeat is generally when
we when we uh consider someone to be
alive or not
alive
um So currently I think that there's a
heartbeat at six weeks maybe eight weeks
maybe 10 weeks but I think around six
weeks uh a baby can have a heartbeat
inside the
womb uh it's very interesting to hear
some some uh arguments about viability
I've I've treated thousands of patients
a lot of very critical patients in my
career U maybe around 10,000 patients
many of them were very severely ill
chronically or acutely or both um I
think that many patients I've treated in
my career have a much worse mortality
rate a worse viability chance than a
baby at 25 weeks which is 50 to 80% I've
had many many patients in my ambulance
whose viability out to out to a few
months was maybe 1% because they were
extremely sever ill yet I could not kill
them that would be called Murder um and
I did not kill them um so that's another
interesting
point another point I want to make is
that government has if it has one or or
two specific purposes it's to protect
life and Liberty and this is one of the
very few things those who know me know I
don't want government to do many things
but if they are to exist they should
protect life life and Liberty so this is
it protecting life of the most
vulnerable because they're babies uh the
fact that they're a baby now and you
think one minute prior to them being
born outside of the uterus they're not a
human that I don't really understand
that logic if they're a baby now they
were a baby they were a human one minute
ago
too
um I think a few people today mentioned
that if these House Bill 622 and 625
pass medical providers won't want to
come to New Hampshire um that has not
been my experience I I moved to New
Hampshire from New York another
Progressive state that that allowed for
abortion it's one of the few other
states with no restrictions I believe
now only eight States including New
Hampshire in New York have no
restrictions on abortions essentially
late ter abortion but I don't know of
any paramedics I don't I know a lot of
paramedics I know fewer doctors and
nurses but I don't know if any medical
provider who enjoys uh killing babies
and I don't think if if these bills
passed people uh doctors nurses medical
providers paramedics would be less
likely to move to New Hampshire because
they didn't have that so-called right to
abort babies um I also want to point out
that this is the the same legislature I
think a year ago that did not pass the
bill that simply would have protected
babies who were born outside of the
uterus who were alive and kicking and
crying uh a bill that would have
prevented them from being killed I think
this legislature stopped that bill and
did not pass it which was disappointing
and rather
disturbing um I think that's pretty much
all I want to say I mean if we talk
about viability and uh Consciousness and
how smart they are we I've had so many
patients who are on ventilators and and
essentially are in the vegetative state
yet I didn't kill them I couldn't kill
them I wouldn't want to kill them it's
not legal to kill them um in fact those
patients or 85 years old might have a
DNR have already lived a long life
whereas babies have not lived yet and
are innocent and have potential to live
and just because they don't have yet
intelligent brains like you and I
doesn't mean we should be uh killing
them so if we use one argument we should
also make it legal to kill all old
people who have moderate to severe
dementia which I'm not in favor of
killing 80 million Americans right now
so thank you very much and that's it
exceeded the three minutes so I'm just
going to ask you to finish up oh that's
all thank you thank you any
questions thank you Mr axelman for your
testimony
today uh we have an
individual who identifies herself as
Cindy s who wishes to
testify hello hello hi hi um yes uh I
support um passing House Bill 625 and
622 um there's so many states that have
restrictions like at 22 weeks at 20
weeks I don't know why New Hampshire is
so backwards on this a woman earlier
said that we keep bringing this up and
we keep bringing this up because it's so
basic um Alabama 22 weeks Arkansas 22
weeks Florida 24 weeks Georgia 22 weeks
Indiana Iowa Kansas Kentucky Louisiana
Massachusetts Mississippi Nebraska
Nevada North Carolina North Dakota Ohio
Oklahoma Pennsylvania South Carolina
South Dakota Texas West Virginia
Wisconsin
Virginia I don't I'm sure I hope that
whoever is voting that you've probably
already made up your minds on how you're
going to vote but I hope that you don't
just vote how you've always voted voted
because New Hampshire doesn't have to be
this way like New Hampshire says
everyone should live free or die but I
think we all know that we'd rather live
free um there's no reason for New
Hampshire to um just be so backwards and
so callous um and so wishy-washy on
abortion um like there's no reason I
don't understand and I hope you guys
just don't always vote the same way
you've been voting um and I just plea
with you that um it's just please do not
have cold Hearts as cold as the weather
is here please do not have cold Hearts
um I I don't know how else to say this
that um they said that um women have a
right to their bodies but there's also
another body and those are women too
they're probably half women and Half Men
um growing inside women's bodies so it's
I just I just beg you and please vote
with your heart that um that yeah babies
fetuses babies are people and they
deserve to live and you cannot just not
six months the The Spill is about six
months you're allowing pregnant you're
allowing abortions at six months and I I
don't think it's unreasonable to pass
this bill today I don't just please um
please change your
minds um it we we're depending on you if
you don't do this it won't happen so
please this is super important okay you
reached the three minute limit okay
thank you so much I love you guys Jesus
loves you any you can do this you can do
it guys I trust in you any questions for
Cindy
s seeing none thank you for your
testimony today thank you uh there there
is a person by the name of Neil hubacher
who wishes to
testify good morning can you hear me you
can good morning Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Neil hubacher I
live in Hollis New Hampshire um although
I do serve as the Director of
Cornerstone Church Ambassador Network
I'm here on behalf of myself and
actually I'm discussing this bill with
my family last night my nine-year-old
daughter Hannah wish to offer her
testimony I will my time
to Hannah my name
is I support H class because
bab I
also thank you for considering our
testimony thank thank you very much are
there any questions for Mr
hubach thanks
again and next speaker will be Nicole
Klein
night um thank you chairman and members
of the committee I'm here as a
representative of New Hampshire
Manchester Ward 4 and I just wanted to
say some things as I watch this live
hearing and I'm here to represent my
people I hear a lot of talk of
compassion and having a heart and and um
you know all these things that we do
need to take in consideration for our
communities and it really troubles me
because I don't see if this were Bill
were to pass any infrastructure on how
to take care of more children that may
not be in a comfortable living situation
a safe living situation or for any
parents that may have not felt prepared
in that moment for whatever personal
reasons I just don't I see that there's
a major black hole here for taking care
of people that already need to be taken
care of and a support system for people
that will be majorly displaced um the
you know are are my my taxpayers here
they want to know how many people we
might need to be putting on assistance
and I think these are fair questions for
any of our people in New Hampshire that
pay taxes and I know my colleagues would
agree on the other side that if this has
an untended consequence of up beinging
of New Hampshire welfare and other
assistances that we have done ourselves
a huge disservice not not only to our
communities and families but our direct
taxpayers and I want that to be mindful
of the people um if you care about human
life I understand but uh you know
there's other unintended consequences
here um and we need to take a look at
that thank you thank you you for your
testimony are there any questions for
representative fine
night see none thank you and we have a
mark dilet who wishes to
testify yes I I'm uh speaking that uh Dr
Damen olssen who was uh scheduled to
speak to you earlier uh in this session
members of the committee uh he was
called to surgery and so he will be
submitting written testimony uh in
support of 625 and we thank you for your
consideration and have a great day thank
you very
much I see no other hands raised at this
time and that being the case I am going
to uh declare that the hearing on house
bills 622 and
625 be
closed We're not scheduled to come back
until 2:00 this afternoon to hear the
remaining bill
today h 4:30 there are 17 speakers who
are scheduled on that bill this
afternoon and we'll play by the same
three minute rule this
afternoon I had anticipated that the
testimony might go longer this morning
particularly based upon the number of
emails we received um so you do have
some time off during lunch time
I when I sent out my email before I just
wanted to let you know that I had asked
if we could we're we're going to be
scheduled to have our hearing our
regular Tuesday hearing on the 16th I
had asked leadership if we could have
the 17th but all of the committee
meeting rooms are full at this point in
time and we're unable to have a hearing
on the
17th uh so you don't need to plan for
that
and um but I think after and we're going
to have session on the 24th and and
25th uh after that we're definitely
going to have to given the number of
bills that we have we're definitely
going to have to double up uh during the
weeks and you can anticipate
that and unless there's some questions
or anything somebody like to
add I think we can recess until 2
o'
yes representative mcth were you just
waving
goodbye okay thank you we'll see you at
all at 2
o'clock thank you
everybody
okay 2
o'clock all
right
I may get a a
napin what you
that represent M you guys aren't
muted thank you have you guys broken for
lunch yeah I think so yes okay I'm sorry
I was just tuned into education I'll put
up um the lunch notice for you guys and
mute your room thank you thank
you you want to mute
that
representative
Chase
for
Jennifer can you hear
me
yeah a number of new
[Music]
Reg raise
hand smaller the hand okay that
worked J 4 can you hear
me
not we can hear you though Kurt Kurt
it's possible that that Jen is covering
more than one
committee oh yeah okay anyway so I don't
know if anybody knows the answer to this
but I was asked is it copy is it
possible to a copy of the quote blue
sheet that is the people who just signed
up and didn't
testify that's a member of the public
wants to know that
I don't
know but they want a list of the names I
guess what else is on the blue
sheet it's all they get to say is who
they are and whether they support or
oppose
right yes there's a sheet which is
published
Ned I don't know if it's me or you but
what I'm getting totally
[Music]
broken
nope
um but I I thought happen if we were
going to email that list to Kurt and he
was going to submit it into
the into the official record so anybody
that went to look at the official record
would have the list at that
time the list of people that testified
right but the other list I mean I
suppose it's public record but I don't
know if because there's phone numbers on
there if we should be giving out
people's phone numbers just nameing
phone number isn't enough to invoke the
Privacy yeah I think it other other
committees have been releasing the list
which is uh what does go in the bill
file and the bill files are going to be
more readily available going forward in
the past when they were
just papers but when we sign in in blue
sheet in a committee room normally we
don't put our phone number down do we no
no I don't think phone number should be
given out and I don't know if people
realizing when they're signing up for
that that th those phone numbers may be
handed out well the blue sheets are a
matter of public record though so if you
want to and again what I'm saying is I
don't think these people realize that
their phone number is being given out I
would be furious if it was me yeah I
would suggest that you ask um Aaron or
Jim
C um
before you do anything else yeah because
the rules as we know it
are
not clear quite I mean what's happening
right now I'm not opposed to redacting
the phone numbers but I don't want this
to become a reason why these things like
don't get released for weeks or months
so they should be
they should be released soon after the
hearing and this is something that I
believe can easily be accomplished
should be accomplished rather than
well I know everyone's busy and stuff
but but if you look at what we had done
outside of this being all digital the
blue sheet just went in the folder and
went into the permanent record the only
time it was ever available somebody
would have to go to the
office and ask to see the blue sheet
well that's correct and I don't think
that was a good way to do it even back
then it was Antiquated even when I
arrived in 2000 December 2008 and it's
it's really Antiquated now so now these
things do exist in a readily postable
form and they should be posted if you
want why don't we find out what what the
official policy is um in in the
house anyway
now
Ned you're on
mute the the room I I just unmuted it
before I came upstairs but it looks like
the room is muted for one reason or
another so represent mlan if you could
unmute the room that should fix
it
reconnected must m it but it
reconnected can you hear us
now
yes thank
you see it right there and see what
their policy is with regard
to
[Music]
Ned you're not
it's what can can can can you hear me
now you're not speaking now
representative Gordon if if you and
representative mlan can you hear us
now yes yes
okay we're
here I'll mute the room if you want to
use your device mic representative
Gordon yes
[Music]
please
okay
jooin and M when it does
so hear
this representative Gordon that's not
working I don't know what's going on but
it's not
working I'm having one of our gcts guys
come over now Ryan should be there
soon
it
I will see
you where
[Music]
back
okay all right
so while we're waiting apparently if you
email house committee services or have
the person email house committee
Services they have um a so-called
cleaned up blue sheet without phone
numbers can you hear me
now anybody yes yes
okay we start
over we're here for House Bill 430
repealing the prohibitions on entering
or remaining on a public way or sidewalk
adjacent to a reproductive Health Care
Facility
[Music]
representative Gordon it's not working
again
since it's uh do you want
to kill that mic and just go off your
computer mic and
uh
so
yep
Jen can you hear
me I can yes is it clear it
is it's not breaking
up not
yet
okay
okay to see if I can hear it
okay okay well give this another
start representative Kelsey would you
like to provide your
testimon yes good afternoon chairman and
good afternoon all the members of the
Judiciary Committee can you hear
me yes my name is Nikki Kelsey I
represent Bedford
Hill I represent Bedford Hillsboro
district 7 I come to you today with
House Bill 430 the sidewalk Free Speech
act freedom of speech is protected not
only by the US Constitution but by the
New Hampshire Bill of Rights our state
constitution is even more adamant than
our federal First Amendment part one
article 22 says that Free Speech should
be inviable preserved yet Free Speech
faces growing threats at both the
federal and the state level from those
who would suppress their opponent speech
because they fear losing an open contest
of
ideas these threats should be reminders
of why the freedom of speech is
protected in our
constitution Supreme Court Justice
William O Douglas won said that freedom
of speech May indeed best serve its high
purpose when it induces a condition of
unrest or even stirs people to anger
speech is often provocative and
challenging that is why freedom of
speech is protected against censorship
or punishment abortion is one issue
where there is definitely unrest on both
sides of the debate but New Hampshire's
buffer zone law represents an attempt to
stifle the contentious debates
surrounding abortion rather than
allowing freedom of speech to serve its
purpose the buffer zone law allows
abortion clinics to demarcate a 25-ft
Zone around clinics in which nobody May
counsel against or protest against
abortion supporters of this buffer zone
law might claim that it functions to
protect women who are seeking an
abortion from being assaulted or
harassed but the truth is that assault
criminal threatening and harassment are
already illegal in New Hampshire the
actual effect of the law is to privilege
pro-abortion speech and marginalized
speech critical of abortion the bill
that I have introduced would repeal the
buffer zone law yet it should Merit the
votes not only of the pro-life or even
those who simply Champion Free Speech
but all of those who value responsible
government that's because in
2014 Massachusetts buffer zone law was
declared unconstitutional by the US
Supreme Court our buffer zone law is
identical in all relevant aspects to the
unconstitutional Mass Massachusetts law
if our buffer zone law is legally
challenged it will be repealed and New
Hampshire will have wasted taxpayers
money defending a law that is not not
only unjust but unconstitutional and
futile for all these reasons the buffer
Lo Zone law should be
repealed thank you for letting me talk
to you guys today and I will answer any
questions yes representative Silber uh
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my question if
the buffer law is repeal this these
sections are repealed uh is it
reasonable to expect that the normal
police presence could maintain order uh
close to these facilities absolutely I
mean it already is a law that harassment
is illegal so yes
absolutely thank you thank you
representative Horgan did you have a
question yeah sure so what was your
statement about how this compared to
Massachusetts law you I don't did you
say literally identical which it is or
just mean that it all that it has the
same effect even though it was fact
written after the McCullen versus K
Supreme Court decision was
made yeah the fact that um clinics can
choose whether or not to activate the
law in New Hampshire it just means that
the plaintiff's lack standing to
challenge it until zone is demarcated by
the conditional nature of the Zone has
nothing to do with
constitutionality so is um is that what
you're
asking um well pretty much I think
that's that I mean that so yeah that's I
guess I I understand your answer I mean
I just yeah committee when we wrote when
we wrote Our version of the bills we um
but I'll leave that for the ex session
this is not the ex session so okay
another question is um how the
and you may not have actually been there
person but how have the demonstrators
have they modified their behavior and
what they do in any way to account for
the co crisis for the last year or
they're just doing the same thing
they've been doing for several years
before that absolutely I have actually
um that's a great question I have been
on the sidewalk with the um with the
sidewalk counselors and they are keeping
their maintaining distance they're
maintaining distance from each other um
they're very respectful this is in no
means um a a loud unrest protest this is
a peaceful protest these men and women
stand on these sidewalks and they pray
and they're very very very peaceful and
they're just out there to offer a
shoulder to cry on or to offer hope or
just an alternative to abortion But to
answer your question specifically about
covid um yeah they are maintaining
distance actually from each other as
well all right thank
all right thank you Mr chair I don't
have any more
questions
representative Gordon can you hear us
are you
[Music]
there
okay
[Music]
I'm sorry I'm having issues with audio
no you're not we can't understand you
representative
Gordon
how this morning and not working
now somehow it worked better when you
were working from home
[Music]
yes hey
guys what we're having issues they have
to reboot the whole system so just
please be patient with
us
for
hello can you hear me now hi guys can
everybody hear me okay
yes can you hear me now
yes
there can you hear me now yes oh great
thank you so what we're going to do is
we're just going to go as if we were
home and I just want to apologize to
everybody they're trying to Rebo reboot
the computer system in the room but
they're not seeming to have very much
success and that's certainly a delay and
I apologize to everybody who's out there
listening for our technical
problems we're back to
4:30 and uh we have heard the testimony
of Representative Kelsey were there any
other questions for representative
Kelsey representative
Langley thank you Mr chair and thank you
represent restive KY for taking my
question um I have a question from my
observation of the of the buffer zone I
understand how this legislation protects
my rights if I were there um as as a
demonstrator sharing information what
I'm not clear about is how it protects
the rights of uh myself if I were there
as a patient going into the clinic and
was not interested in being in receed of
the information being shared can you
help me understand that better
absolutely that's a great question thank
you um so the the law protects the women
from um harassment let's be this is not
this is not harassment the the sidewalk
demonstrators um they stay out of the
parking lot they're not anywhere near
the um the women that are going into the
abortion clinic they are outside of the
parking lot there is security at Planned
Parenthood they are being protect
protected this is a free speech issue
though because these people that are on
the sidewalk have a right to um to
speech and they have a right to
peacefully assemble and they're mostly
praying and and like I said offering um
Alternatives but the right of the women
going into the abortion clinics um they
also are protected and like I said
they're protected under the law from
harassment they're not being harassed so
I hope that answers your question thank
you representative yes are there any
other questions for representative
Kelsey seeing none thank you for your
testimony today thank you so much for
having
me as we did um earlier today uh I
listed off an several names at a time of
people who we expect to testify next I'm
just going to ask those people who I
called to raise their hands on the on
the zoom app so that we know where to
find them uh when it's time to call upon
them uh the next few
Witnesses uh will be uh Dr David
Conway Margaret
shuran uh representative Jess
Edwards uh Dr Young and sathik
nura and I will call upon uh Dr Conway
next if he's
available and I do not see Dr
Conway on our
list
and I do see Jess Edwards Jess do you
want to uh representative Edwards do you
want to speak uh thank you very much sir
um I'm representative Jess Edwards
representing Rockingham District 4
that's Auburn Chester and Sandown uh
I've I've been in committee before uh
hearing this testimony in a previous
life um and one thing that just left me
long after we voted on this bill is that
as legislators were sworn to uphold the
Constitution and the woman's right to uh
terminate her pregnancy in the first
trimester is a is clearly a
constitutionally protected medical
procedure one that we should uh do what
we need to do to
protect um balanced against that is the
group that wants to exercise their
constitutional rights uh under the First
Amendment what we've done to them is
we've put them into this weird Catch 22
where they can't
resolve uh their situation because we
have a law on the books that I don't
think is identical to what was struck
down in Massachusetts but it's really
close enough to where if it were ever
tested it it it it could easily be
unconstitutional um and but yet uh
because um these are law-abiding people
they've not violated the law and
therefore the law has never been
enforced and therefore they are not able
to um have standing in order to bring
forward a case
toity so so we've created this just
weird
catch22 that just doesn't seem like it's
good government I think I think we
should um go ahead and remove this law
from the books it's not being enforced I
mean it's intentionally probably not
being enforced but yet it's chilling
this the Free Speech rights of a group
of people that that are knowable and
again I I I do not want to intrude on
the rights of the women to receive their
medical procedures um because those are
constitutionally protected but but fair
is fair we should respect everyone's
first or respect everyone's
constitutional rights I think and
getting rid of this law would do that I
think I'll take questions if there are
any thank you for your testimony are
there any questions for representative
Edwards
seeing none again thank you for your
testimony
today we have uh Dr oie Young is he
available to
testify do not see
him on our list of
attendees he's there Mr chair can you
hear me yep we can hear you now and and
do you see me anywhere we do oh okay
great go go ahead with your testimony
thank you uh my name's uh Dr o young uh
I'm a retired obstetrician gynecologist
having practiced uh in conquered for
over 35 years I'm past president uh a
past president of the New Hampshire
Medical Society and I continue to serve
on the general Council representing uh
all
obss uh in the state of New Hampshire
remain an Adjunct professor at the Gea
School of
Medicine uh having taught their students
uh for almost 40 years now I'm here
representing the New Hampshire Medical
Society and New Hampshire uh women in
opposition to House Bill
430 uh the repeal of this buffer uh Zone
law this statue uh was made law in
2014 and and I remember well its passage
and also successfully defending this law
uh from repeal in
2018 the statute stands simply to
protect the privacy of patients and
caregivers while respecting the freedom
of speech for those who are opposed to
women seeking Health Care at a facility
uh which also provides abortion I just
want to make two points very simple
uh first of all we need to understand
that less than 5% of women's visits to
Planned Parenthood clinics or clinics
like them who provide abortion
care um come for a termination of of
pregnancy most women present for
wellness
exams uh Health screenings like
mammograms and
papsmear and importantly many
request uh contracep ction to prevent
unplanned and unwanted
pregnancies the precipitous drop in
abortions in New Hampshire and
Nationwide is clearly
because uh of improved access to
contraception we should celebrate this
trend the last thing we want to do is
limit education about and access to
birth control
uh by repealing this buffer zone
law now we've heard uh several people
say that that these people outside of uh
these
clinics um don't prevent
access but uh it's very clear to me
having talked with many women uh they're
an intimidating presence and I know that
there are women who come to see me for
their care because they don't feel
comfortable going to a clinic with a
crowd of people around the clinic uh
protesting abortion I can't imagine how
intimidating it would be if those people
were allowed allowed to go closer than
the buffer zone uh even on the front
steps or in the waiting area um I
certainly wouldn't tolerate that you
where my office
was uh the second point I want to make
and sometimes this is misunderstood but
the US Supreme Court decision roie
Wade handed down 48 years ago was not
determined on the premise to protect
women's right to
choice is often misunderstood It Was
Written solely to protect the privacy of
the patient caregiver
relationship clearly repealing the
buffer zone law would jeopardize the
sacred privacy which protects patients
and providers and even those
protesting the use of those Health Care
Facilities okay I'm happy any any
questions you might have for me thank
you Dr Young are the questions for Dr
Young
yeah I got representative silur yes
thank you for Mr chairman thank you
doctor for taking my question you
indicated concern about the repeal of
the law would allow people to come into
your waiting area uh is there is your
waiting area not private is there any
reason why uh in a in a private facility
you can't control who comes into your
facility or
not I I would not not invite anyone
there who would disrupt the privacy of
my relationship with my
patients a followup please yes you
may I just wondering how you can
reconcile your support of maintaining
the statute that they're seeking to
repeal against the following language
Congress shall make no law respecting
the right of the people peaceably to
assemble which is from the First
Amendment and applicable to the states
through the 14th Amendment how do you
reconcile that with your position on
this bill I reconcile it because of the
decision of roie
way I don't I I don't think there should
be any disruption of privacy between the
relationship my my my my patient and and
me as a care
provider thank you
representative
mlan thank you Mr chair and and thank
you for taking my question um the uh the
prime sponsor on this bill mentioned
that um as you said this has been lost
since
2014 but in all that time it's it's
never been implemented in spite of of
the the fact that the proponents say it
is so urgently needed and I remember uh
the move uh to years ago to repeal the
bill and there was a clinic coordinator
and I asked her at the time why why have
you not implemented it and she said well
we're we're close there are certain
logistic elements we have to put in
place certain conversations we have to
have with law enforcement and yet here
we are two years later and we still
don't see any implementation anywhere in
spite of this perceived need so in your
role um with the New Hampshire Medical
Society
I'm just trying to get some insight as
to what your thinking is to why it has
not actually been implemented um you
know seven years after its
passage say that again what what what
hasn't been implicated the buffer
zone the the the law is in effect but it
has not been
implemented uh at any facility so no
while while facilities have the right to
enact this buffers Zone they're not
actually doing it and and like I said
when I spoke to the clinic coordinator a
couple years ago they said well there
are logistic issues we have to handle we
in conversations with law enforcement so
we're close yet we have not had any
actual implementation of the buffer zone
in the state so as I said I was just
wondering in Your Capacity with the New
Hampshire Medical Society in your
discussion with your members um do you
have any insight as to why that is so
you're talking about I'm trying to to
understand what you mean by
implementation somebody going out there
and enforcing the buffer zone is that is
that what you're saying it hasn't been
implemented it hasn't had to be
implemented because I think the law is
there uh if somebody sits on the front
porch or is in the waiting room I think
it would be
implemented the buffer zone law is there
so that there doesn't have to be force
in that situation that's the the last
thing we want on both sides of this
issue thank you uh representative
Alexander um thank you Mr chair and uh
thank you doctor for taking my question
um I'm really torn on this because we
see um precedent for um buffer zones and
other areas so talk in the Supreme Court
there's a 35- foot buffer zone um
outside of a polling location when
people go to vote for Representatives
like us um there's a 10- foot wide
Corridor that's in the uh New Hampshire
rsas um this this buffer zone would pres
prohibit dis demonstrations for any
reason and the speech isn't necessarily
or the demonstration is not necessar not
specifically targeted so I guess what
I'm wondering is maybe so if somebody
wanted to
protest um the rent in the city of
Manchester because it's too high would
they be able to stand on the sidewalk
right next to the plan Parenthood clinic
and
protest I mean so protesting a different
issue than than
abortion I I don't know somebody else
have to answer that for me I I would
think the buffer zone around the uh
facility uh stands for for any kind of
protest u i mean it's a 25 foot buffer
zone so that um well so that we can
create
as comfortable environment for clients
approaching the facility as as as as
there there can be I can tell you even
with that 25 foot buffer zone many of
women are are uh intimidated by by the
presence of people on the
sidewalk okay thank you I hopefully if
followup Mr chair if somebody else has
the answer to this um I'd appreciate
that
answer representative wer you had your
qu you had your hand up but no longer do
you wish to ask a
question uh am I muted probably no okay
so uh no representative Alexander Mor
asked the same question that I had head
uh and I don't see any value in pursuing
that with Dr Young thank
you any other questions
comments seeing none thank you doctor
thank you very much right uh the next
person I have on the list is Margaret
shuran is Margaret shuran
available do not see her on the list of
attendees next person who signed up is
sathvik
nura and I don't see that name on the
list of
attendees uh the next uh people to be
called will be uh representative
Abramson
cayb
Montgomery Alia
Ana Beth
Jorgenson and Patrice
Meyers and representative Abramson are
you available to
testify are you guys able to hear me we
are all right thank you my name is
representative Max abam I'm going to
have to speak kind of quickly um because
i' I've got another Committee hearing
going on at the same time um so this
bill was in 2014 or this statute RSA
132 sections 37 through 40 um this is
based on model legislation in
Massachusetts which was implemented in
Massachusetts which had a 35t rule and
so I've heard a few people saying that
it's probably uncon constitutional
because theirs was 35 ft and ours is 25
ft so we don't know but actually um the
US Supreme Court was looking at 23 feet
um and if I can pull the exact wording
from the decision they said uh in a
summary of The Facts the clinic occupies
its own building on a street corner its
main door is recessed into an open foyer
approximately 12T back from the public
sidewalk before the Act was amended to
create buffer zones petitioners stood
near the Entry Way of the
foyer now a buffer zone marked by a
painted Arc and a sign surrounds the
entrance this Zone extends 23 feet down
the sidewalk in One Direction and 26
feet in the other and outward just one
foot short of the curb so they were
looking at 23 feet and so the US Supreme
Court has already said that 23 feet is
is too much they've decided not to get
into the middle ground and decide what's
an acceptable distance but um they
weren't basing this on roie Wade they
weren't basing this on an abortion issue
they they were basing this um more even
than freedom of speech was the idea that
one business could not use state law to
prevent uh competing
business with a competing service from
offering an alternative to um potential
customers um and so this this statute
there's no question that it's
unconstitutional as written and there
are several problems with just leaving a
statute even if it's not currently
enforced someone will eventually try to
enforce it and be willing to to put
their um expose their town to uh costly
litigation um one of the problems we ran
into on Municipal and County leaving in
place laws that were unconstitutional or
adding laws that were
unconstitutional was that a lot of small
towns uh when they look at statutes they
have a tendency to assume that they'll
they're constitutional and they'll stand
up in court and just leaving even a
handful of unconstitutional statutes in
place creates problems because uh
contract law has to be legal you can't
have un you can't have illegal contract
Provisions you can't have requirements
people
follow um carry out some unlawful act um
the signs that they had the municipal
have to put up the lines that they have
to put up out there um police training
frequently and um uh EMT training
frequently refers to what's written in
rsas um they have to be able to rely on
the fact that the rsas that we maintain
in the in the law books are valid and
are going to hold up in court and aren't
going to lead to other problems
with uh Free Speech issues Fair Housing
Act Americans with Disabilities Act or
cause some other uh uh conflict um if
every time an elected official at the
local level um I serve on my Town's
planning board if we have to consult an
attorney every time we want to look up a
statute it's going to uh drastically
increase the cost um we're used to just
going to RSA 674 and 676 and some of the
others and simply reading those statutes
as is on the assumption that it's
constitutional and it'll stand up in
court so when we make decisions on the
planning board or budget committee or
anything else we have a tendency to
assume that the legislators did their
job of of removing anything that might
cause
legal uh legal problems later on uh so
for that reason I think that we've got
to pass this bill and and repeal the
statute um we frequently introduce bills
to repeal statutes after the courts have
ruled something
unconstitutional and I think it's just
it's part of the job
um uh of being
lawmakers okay thank you thank you for
your testimony are there questions for
representative
Abramson by the way representative
pulper I like your
tie I got the same one
on thank you thank you very much thank
you the next witness is Caleb m
g uh good afternoon members of the House
Judiciary Committee my name is Kayla
Montgomery I'm the director of public
affairs for PL parent of New Hampshire
action fund and pl parent of Northern
New England and we oppose house full
4:30 uh so first just as some background
here uh this body passed Senate Bill 319
and it was signed into law back in
2014 and this legislation was to address
public safety concerns by allowing a
non-mandatory buffer zone of up to 25 ft
and I just want to stress that it's up
to 25t so it could be 5 feet it could be
10 feet it could be 25 but this
flexibility allows for communities to
tailor a Zone in accordance to local
factors and local public safety needs so
I just want to explain a little bit
about why um patients and providers need
the flexibility to use a buffer zone
reproductive health centers in New
Hampshire have never been free of
picketing and protest activity however
in the past few years and particularly
since the pandemic began the volume and
frequency of protesters have increased
currently ppnne uses on-site Security on
certain days and calls to the police are
more frequent these types of har of
harassing tactics which have become
routine for patients and staff include
obstructing the driveway entrance
blocking on street parking spaces verbal
assaults photographing patients and
staff and posting them online to
generate further harassment protesters
Gather in front of the entrance and
create barriers for patients trying to
enter the Health Center and they invade
the privacy of those who do not wish to
engage in dialogue with them while
entering or exiting the building and
this is a public safety concern so as
was already mentioned um buffer zones
have been a topic of litigation but as
recently as last month the United States
Supreme Court upheld a decision by the
third uh us Circuit Court of Appeals and
left in place a buffer zone in
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania and as was also
mentioned locally in
2016 uh the US District Court dismissed
the challenge to New Hampshire's buffer
zone case and it was reaffirmed by the
US Circuit Court of Appeals in
2017 so establishing a buffer zone is
really just one tool in the toolkit for
health centers and local authorities to
use when working together to protect
Public Safety and privacy to patients
and providers while also balancing First
Amendment rights so while it's not
necessarily the first or the only tool
Health Centers and communities must have
the flexibility to use the buffer zone
if needed Public Safety is critical and
a New Hampshire specific buffer zone law
allows patients a safe and private
passage to a health center this law is
not mandated every reproductive Health
Center and every Community faces
different concerns this simply gives
communities and health centers the
flexibility to use the buffer zone to
maintain Public Safety as needed no one
should face harassment violence or
threats when accessing safe legal Health
Care everyone from the governor two
legislators to patients deserve to feel
safe so in conclusion plan Hood
recognizes and fully supports the right
to Peaceful free speech and having a
tool in place to adopt a buffer zone
around Health Centers does not remove
Free Speech it just gives local Health
Centers including patients providers and
volunteers a small area of separation
for privacy and we urge you to ex exped
to legislate house 430 and keep this
carefully balanced law um and I also
just before I end I'd like to just come
back to a question that um
representative Langley had for the
sponsor about balancing rights um like I
said this morning when I mentioned in my
testimony that every pregnancy is unique
I would say that anyone who comes to
plan Parenthood and stands outside of uh
the house center is also unique there
are people who are very peaceful and
there are also some people that aren't
and that's why this bill gives us the
flexibility when it comes to
protections thank you thank you for your
testimony representative Sylvia did you
have a question yes thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question you referred to the buffer zone
as non-mandatory but in Reading RSA 132
col 38 Roman 2 it starts reproductive
Health Care Facilities shall clearly
demarcate The Zone authorized in
paragraph one that doesn't seem to be
non-mandatory that seems to be mandatory
can you explain your thinking on
that
um you know I don't have that language
in front of me but this bill is not
mandatory um the buffer zone is not
mandatory every Health Center and every
Community is going to face different
challenges and some are going to need it
and some are not going
to thank you representative
Burch thank you Mr chair and uh thank
you uh Miss Montgomery for uh taking my
question you you testified that the
Supreme Court last
month um allowed a uh buffer zone to
continue at in
Pittsburgh uh is it not true that the
Supreme Court also last
year left in place Chicago's 8 foot
floating bubble Zone and harrisburg's 20
foot fixed buffer
zone that's correct uh not all buffer
zones are unconstitutional and we're
seeing that thank
you you and representative
mlan thank you Mr chair and and thank
you for taking my question um I just
want to follow up a little bit on the
same question um I asked Dr Young
earlier and maybe you have some
additional Insight you make a pretty uh
compelling case for the buffer zone as
to why it's needed um and yet as as the
prime P sponsor said it it it has never
been actually implemented you know and
given the the compelling need can you
maybe give some insight as as to why in
the time since the law has been passed
it hasn't been
implemented sure uh thank you for the
question uh as I did mention um Planned
Parenthood believes that a buffer zone
is just one tool in maintaining public
safety and not necessarily again not
necessarily the first or the only tool
so uh we work with local authorities to
review incremental steps and options and
new ways to implement mitigation
techniques against disruptive protests
they take time to implement and uh I
think it's really important to note that
some of this progress has been
understandably delayed while our
Manchester Health Center underwent
renovations to the building to modernize
the space this included um renovations
to the parking lot um
and this all just wrapped up last month
and so we look forward to continuing
ongoing discussions about ways to limit
dist disruption of protesters with the
city stakeholders and I will also add
that we have and will continue to have
thoughtful communication with
Manchester's new police chief and mayor
to determine the best course to maintain
Public Safety but we need the
flexibility in order to do
so representative Alexander um thank you
Mr chair um thank you uh Miss Montgomery
for taking my question um I just want to
follow up on representative McLean's
question um so if if um the buffer zone
law was repealed in New Hampshire um
would Planned Parenthood have um other
tools in the toolbox to um make sure the
Reproductive Rights of women are
protected um in New Hampshire thank
you um yes of course but um you know we
we do things constantly we've like I
mentioned we uh work with the Manchester
Police Department there have been
increased patrolling in the area we've
been adding as a hot spot um we continue
to engage in these conversations but
that doesn't change the fact that the
buffer zone is an important tool and
whether we use it or whether we don't
it's there and that's what's
important any other questions for M
Montgomery
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today thank
you and Beth
Jorgenson hi my name is um Beth
Jorgenson and I'm uh a resident of
Bedford for the last 35 years um I
believe that um HB
430 uh is a bill that should pass um I
personally am one of the folks who go
and pray um outside the planed parthood
on Penacook Street in Manchester I've
been doing that for about 10 years um
there are usually maybe five people
there sometimes 10 we walk up and down
um and we pray and offer pamplets or
help to anyone that's going in um the
people present are very polite we offer
help to anyone you know who's interested
and I have never seen any threatening
shaming or or anything like that that's
disruptive to the people uh that are
going in and in regard to their privacy
which um the doctor spoke about earlier
I really don't understand that because
we're folks that are outside they don't
know our name we don't know their name
and we're not preventing anyone from
doing anything all do is stay on the
actual side Sidewalk we don't go into
the parking lot because that's um
private property and no one enters the
clinic um and if people don't want to
speak with us they just go in and you
know that that's
fine um as I understand this buffer law
would cause us to have to move across
the street so that if you wanted to
speak with anyone that was walking in
you wouldn't be able to you you'd be too
far away um and that's basically just
what I wanted to let you know that I
actually have personal experience going
there and you know exercising our our
right to peacefully protest and I
haven't ever seen you know any any
problem where anyone is being I think
the word used was
harassed um so thank you for letting me
speak to this and I would urge you to
remove this um this particular law
because um it doesn't seem necessary and
I think would
prevent um those of us who are there
peacefully exercising our right to free
speech so thank
you any questions for Miss
Jorgenson thank you for your testimony
today uh the next person I had was Alia
Ana
hello can you hear me we can hear you
all right members of the committee and
chair thank you for letting me speak
again since I was at the earlier talk my
name is Alia Ana I'm from hooks at New
Hampshire and I'm the president of
students for life at the University of
New Hampshire on behalf of the club
members and the exec members I support
House Bill 430 established in the First
Amendment of the Constitution and the
New Hampshire Bill of Rights in part one
article 22 citizens have the right to
free speech Massachusetts already got
rid of the buffer zone law due to it
being
unconstitutional while Planned
Parenthood and Kayla Mon guttery and
workers at abortion facilities are
scared of are mostly peaceful
individuals specifically sidewalk
counselors from 40 Days for life and
other organizations
peacefully standing outside of their
establishments and being a listening ear
to women in their troubles by providing
resources to other pregnancy centers if
they
ask especially since in the state of New
Hampshire there are twice as many
Pregnancy Care Centers in the state
compared to abortion facilities
including P Planned Parenthood as an
African-American woman I have the
capacity to advocate for the protection
of black women and men specifically I'm
advocating for the lives of black
mothers and babies because they will be
the future generation of black people
standing outside of a facility
advocating for the protection of black
lives within their mother's wombs is no
different than people walking across a
street to protest police brutality I
never promote violence against anyone
including the people working at Planned
Parenthood and other abortion facilities
Kila mon gy mentioned that
she has worked with police officers in
order to lower lower harassment but I
wonder if that's the case then why do we
need a buffer law in the first place
what I'm trying to say is please pass
4:30 to protect constitutional freedom
in the lives of their future generation
of men and women black lives matter and
they have always mattered this includes
men women born children and pre-born
children Planned Parenthood and other
facilities and the lives of at a higher
rate than white people thank
you thank you representative Horgan did
you have a
question oh sure why not yes this is
represent Horgan um my question was are
are you uh you may not even be aware of
this incident but there were some
antivaccine demonstrators who blocked a
site in California so would you would
you favor protecting that activity or
just activity aimed at preventing this
one particular medical procedure are you
divorcing in terms of preventing people
from getting vaccines as someone who is
in the health care field I do believe it
is okay for someone to get a vaccine and
I think it would be ridiculous for antia
to force that onto people who want to
get a vaccine but comparing getting a
vaccine to a woman getting abortion in
my opinion is apples to
oranges are there other questions from
isans zingan thank you for your
testimony again today representative
Langley did you have a
question I did thank you Mr chair I
wonder this is this is more curiosity
than anything else but I wonder thank
you for taking my question do you have
any sense of how many women um ask
voluntarily ask for information as
they're going into a Planned Parenthood
facility from demonstrators on the
outside do you have any of that well in
terms
of going to hear stories in regards to
people going to these people standing
outside of an abortion facility Well I
have personally been in a situation
where I participated in a 40 Days for
Life event with me and another person I
have not personally witnessed that but
I've heard stories of women who have had
abortions who have regretted it and if
there were people standing outside of
the facility offering other options for
parenting and for adoption they wouldn't
have had the
procedure thank
you
other
questions seeing none thank again thank
you for your testimony again
today and the next person is Patrice
Meyers Patrice Meers with
us I do not see
her so the next group of
people will be uh een
alers Susan
Clifton Kathleen
yanan Jane
ha and Susan Bruce and if you would just
raise your hands on the Zoom app and so
we can see whether you're there or not
and so I call upon Eileen aers to
testify thank you Mr chairman and
committee members I am Eileen AER from
hookit I'm speaking for myself in
opposition to House Bill
430 I am going to share some experiences
that I have as a Volunteer Clinic escort
at equality Health Center in conquer
it's a few blocks south on main street
from where you are at the State House
the stairway entrance is on the public
sidewalk and there is no patient parking
lot I emailed each of you several times
uh with my written test testimony photos
and an audio recording as evidence of
what I
experience you saw the lay of the land
the proximity of the protesters their
encampment their signs their lack of
masks the crowding at the stairway you
heard the yelling and bullying of the
protesters not all protesters require
the equality Health Center to have
escorts present some are very peaceful
and they don't interrupt anybody but for
past two years every Friday morning a
new group has been assembling there and
I've been there every Friday morning as
well they do a double duty they shame
the women and they evangelize their
religious
Dogma women are rushing to the doctor
appointment they have no interest in
hearing a man on the sidewalk a stranger
tell her what to do to her body
according to his
religion the yelling the shaming the
intimidating The Graphic Signs the body
cameras worn by two of the men that are
trained on each of us it's an actual
Gauntlet of harassment that the women
must run where else does this happen
does it happen to you when you go to the
doctors a 25- foot buffer has not been
enacted but it is a community safety net
to keep in place if a clinic chooses to
use it for now I am the buffer zone I
stand between patients and
protesters it's
risky I need to stay vigilant but I'm
there for the safety of everyone there
have been times escorts have had to
deescalate potential violence between
the patient
their partners and the
protesters last month we had a
considerable snowstorm and the sidewalk
got even
narrower I let an interpreter into the
building and then the non-english
speaking patient
arrived I went to her and the men
started yelling waving their signs
leaning in very
close I looked at her she looked at me
with sheer Terror in her
eyes I put an arm around her to hurry
her past she was frozen she had fear she
was
shaking this was a blatant violation of
the face act the freedom of access for
Clinic entrances it's been engaged since
1994 nationally and
prohibits someone causing fear for their
safety entering a
clinic this is is not okay this is
dangerous if this were truly a bill that
would limit Free Speech I'd be voting
against it I've been protesting and
demonstrating for the last 55 years of
my life but it is not about abortion
it's not about
religion it's about keeping the First
Amendment and Public Safety we can
protest and we can have access to a
clinic
simultaneously a 25 foot buffer does not
take away the freedom of speech and
nowhere are you guaranteed the right to
be heard you can speak at in my face 10
feet away 25 feet away there is no limit
to
speech across the country there is a lot
of vandalism going on assaults bomb
threats at
clinics at any given day that Happ could
happen in New Hampshire I think we need
to keep the buffer zone law in place
should the threat
arise not all patients and not all
clinics are equally vulnerable the
physical location of the equality Health
Center is very public and close so I
hope that you've listened to the
protester audio that I sent you I hope
you've listened and watched the women
who try to enter in our shame
and scorned and lectured
to but most of all I hope that you will
vote in expedient to legislate on this
Bill thank you thank you for your
testimony representative rice did you
have a
question yes thank you very much Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question um due to um your concern on
the dangerousness of this have the
conquer police been called in to help
with this situation thank you for the
question representative yes conquered
police are on the scene frequently
multiple Cruisers several police
officers uh sometimes it's the
protesters who call because they don't
want to be told to back off I'm over 73
years old I have heart disease I'm a
diabetic if I catch Corona virus I will
likely die these people are less than
two feet away from me and very often not
masked the police officers came and told
them to put on masks and to keep their
distance they don't distance from each
other from us for the patients many
times pedestrians coming down the
sidewalk walk into the street behind
parked cars to avoid them they are a
danger to me even when they're not
protesting so yes the police have been
called many
times follow up Mr chairman yes you may
but but they haven't no one's been
arrested they're only just telling them
to keep their distance if if that's the
case why aren't you guys um implementing
the the buffer
zone well that is above my pay grade I'm
a volunteer I don't make those decisions
but um no there have been no arrest
there was a time when one patient's
partner was almost arrested because of a
violent eruption between the protesters
and this man which the escorts
de-escalated and stopped um
I don't think we want to wait for for
arrests and when people talk about it's
not harassment well the women going
in have already lost a lot of privacy
with videos and and audios being taken
and published on Facebook a lot of them
don't want to know have the public know
that they're having an abortion it might
be a stigma and for them to press press
charges and go to court you're not
likely to see that
happen
you all set representative rice yes
thank you very much thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony today you're
welcome uh the next person is uh Susan
Clifton hi can you hear
me we can hear you with an echo
okay hold on I'm just adjusting
this okay can you hear me now is that
better that's much better okay thank
you my name is Susan Clifton and I live
in
Sandown and I wanted to thank the
committee today for the opportunity to
speak for a minute
I've been um a resident of Sandown for
about 35 years I speak in favor of House
Bill 430 the sidewalk Free Speech act I
am a retired
nurse and a sidewalk counselor and have
been going weekly to plan Parenthood in
Manchester for over 15
years to offer help and hope and also
prayer support to the women going
inside although
it seems to be not the case in
Manchester we are we are very much
opposed to any kind of threatening or
um disruptive protesting we we maintain
a peaceful environment on pentac street
of course we don't have any control over
anybody who who shows up but um our
experience has been for the most part we
are peaceful we don't threaten anyone we
offer help and if they refuse we just
quietly back back off we don't um want
to intimidate anybody we're
law-abiding and um I'm I'm speaking to
say that although this legislation for
the buffer zone started out being just
about abortion we know this type of
legislation will impact all kinds of
speech and so I'm asking that we just
clean this up so that our first
amendment rights basic to our freedoms
are protected no matter the content of
the
speech and uh basically that's all
wanted to say I want to thank you for
your
time thank you for your testimony and
are there
questions I see none again thank you for
your testimony here
today and the next person is Jane
ha Jane heg
available do not see her I know she
testified this
morning and Susan
Bruce Susan
Bruce okay can you hear me now we we can
hear you
excellent uh good afternoon Mr chairman
and members of the Judiciary Committee
my name is Susan Bruce I live in conquer
and I'm here to testify in opposition to
HB 430 the bill to repeal the buffer
zone law this is a bad idea for all of
New Hampshire's reproductive Health
Centers and by the way not all of New
Hampshire's reproductive health centers
are affiliated with Planned Parenthood
there seems to be a little confusion
about that I'm going to speak most I'm
going to speak about conquered because I
live here and I'm familiar with what
happens here and as you heard in earlier
testimony here in conquer we have a
group of individuals who oppose a
woman's right to bodily autonomy and
gather every Friday morning to protest
in front of the equality Health
Center there is very little room between
the sidewalk and the stairs that lead up
to the center as you can see in the
photos that I sent you these are not
Pious folk who stand and pray these are
not sidewalk counselors unless your idea
of counseling involves being bellowed at
in the most demeaning and offensive ways
these are people who want to shout at
and shame women they have no trouble
being heard they're fewer than eight
feet away from patients they would reach
out and grab women or follow them to
their cars if they could the only thing
that stops them is the escort
tell me men of this committee do any of
you require escorts to guard you through
a shouting throng in order to see your
doctor I urge you all to go and witness
this for yourselves some Friday morning
the protesters are
obnoxious the residents and businesses
in the area despise them they are so
loud that the people who live in the
apartment building next door frequently
shut out their Windows telling the
protesters to shut up pedestrians will
walk out into the street around parked
cars in order to avoid
them the protesters also wear body
cameras and videotape the women as they
run through the screaming Gauntlet to
enter the building in a clear violation
of their privacy and they post videos on
YouTube all this so that women can
access a legal medical procedure the
sponsors of this bill have loftily named
this the sidewalk Free Speech act I
assure you no one is curtailing the free
speech of these protesters you may call
this Free Speech but it isn't the kind
of free speech that any of you would
tolerate in your own lives it is
harassment it is verbal abuse it is a
form of terrorism if someone were doing
this to you you would call the police
you might even perhaps stand your ground
I urge you not to repeal the buffer zone
law we all know that it's not used or
enforced but it is a symbol the repeal
of the bill tells the protesters that
it's open season on women's clinics it
sends the message that they can already
be they can be more vile than they
already are it also paves the way for
Clinic violence New Hampshire is already
home to a number of domestic terrorists
and hate groups the white supremacist
movement is closely tied to the
anti-abortion movement this bill is not
necessary is Grand in by people who
claim to be prif passing it will only
serve to hurt the women that the
sponsors care claim to care about thank
you for
listening are questions for Miss Bruce
I've just been giving not bones that's
what said seeing none thank you for your
testimony today these are
ones uh I I have Kathleen
yanan is she available to
testify
thought I saw her on the
[Music]
list she has to unmute Mr
chair is she
muted
or she looks like she's muted on her end
okay we'll come back if that's the case
uh the next uh group to be called is
Carol K
nitzki Kane McIntyre Michael King
Jennifer friselle and Francis
hin and is Carol kitki available if you
all would raise your hands on the zoom
Zoom app that would be
helpful again that was Carol cos nitzki
Tanya McIntyre Michael King Jennifer
friselle and Francis
Hines and is Carol kitki
available do not see
her Tanya
McIntyre
Michael
King I know Michael King testified
earlier today go sit
down Jennifer friselle I know you're
there Mr chairman can we ask people to
mute because I keep hearing someone's
background
noise yes I I do too so if there's
someone that uh is not muted as a panel
member they should be
muted is Jennifer frelle
available I think I'm here okay would
you like to
testify yes thank you chairman Gordon
and members of the House Judiciary
Committee for the record I am Jennifer
felle and I work as the Director of
policy for the New Hampshire women's
Foundation uh the women's foundation
invests in equality and opportunity for
women and girls through research
advocacy education and
philanthropy as a grantmaking
organization we provide financial
support to community organizations
including several that provide
reproductive Health Care to women and
teens and are impacted by the
legislation before you and as an
advocacy and a research organization uh
we prioritize a number of bills each
year that are critical and impact
women's fundamental rights and access to
health care services and we're here
today in opposition to House Bill
4:30 we opposed because we believe that
women should have access to the full
range of reproductive choices and
related Health Care coverage and that
people should be able to access
reproductive and sexual health care
services without harassment or intim
idation while I'm here speaking for the
New Hampshire women's Foundation I was
working as an attorney at planed
Parenthood when this law passed earlier
uh about eight years ago and so I do
have some history and may address a few
points that I heard as part of my
testimony the New Hampshire PA patient
safety law should be upheld uh for the
following reasons um in New Hampshire
patients should be able to access health
care without confrontation or
harassment um you've already heard and
I'm not going to R my testimony um the
compelling stories from representatives
from Planned Parenthood as well as from
escorts about the type of uh aggressive
body language and harsh and abusive
verbal language that some patients
experience uh while recognizing there
are many peaceful and per uh peripheral
post uh protesters whose rights need to
be accommodated and are addressed uh in
the balance that is Incorporated in our
current patient safety law this law was
carefully
crafted to be able to meet many
constitutional considerations including
many that have uh been raised for you
here today um several have suggested
that this law is so substantially
similar to Massachusetts law that it's
most certainly
unconstitutional um I would sign
significantly disagree with that on
multiple points um while New Hampshire's
law was being drafted uh it was um well
aware to the drafters and The Advocates
that there were some concerns that the
court had raised in the oral argument in
the Massachusetts case and this law in
New Hampshire is specifically crafted to
be more narrowly tailored than that
Massachusetts law it is not a one-size
fits-all uh proposition where every
reproductive Health Care uh facility in
the state is subject to the same
mandatory provision where in the New
Hampshire I mean the Massachusetts law
that was struck down um that was one of
the concerns that the Supreme Court
articulated that there should be no more
um assembly or speech restricted than is
necessary and therefore when laws and
ordinances like this are passed to
balance free speech and Public Safety
they should be narrowly tailored if
possible at the community
level um the the other way that New
Hampshire's law is different is it's up
to 25 uh feet so as youve heard more
recent representative from plan
Parenthood testify today there's
significant flexibility in how large a
z ra your hand the other thing I want to
point out because of the suggestion that
New Hampshire's law is so similar to
Massachusetts that it should surely be
unconstitutional is there were
plaintiffs including perhaps some of the
people who are supporting this repeal
who actually brought that case they
brought it in the case of ready versus
attorney general Joe Foster the very law
in front of you was challenged um our
own Attorney General's office defended
the law and its existence in federal
court and while the judge did not have
to answer multiple questions because he
determined that the plaintiffs did not
have standing one of the questions that
the judge was asked to answer was is
this law facially unconstitutional and
what that means in lawyer talk is are
there no circumstances under which this
law could be applied in a constitutional
Manner and the judge did not reach that
conclusion and I would think it's very
important both for the providers who
have advocated today on behalf of their
patients about why and how this law is
still needed that the committee continue
to allow for the flexibility that this
uh option provides at the local
community level and not feel that it in
fact under no circumstances would meet
even the current standards of the
Supreme Court I also know it was
mentioned and so I want to emphasize um
that just as recently as last month uh
the US Supreme Court with its current
composition allowed to stand uh 15 foot
buffer zone in the city of of Pittsburgh
around a reproductive health clinic so
there areas that this law might be
useful in New Hampshire that could be
constitutionally crafted to balance free
speech and Public Safety and we would
ask you to um continue to leave this law
on the books um I did want to raise um a
few responses I know representative
Alexander had asked a question very
specific about statutes that are content
neutral as opposed to statutes that
address a specific issue or a specific
type of speech um and I just wanted to
Echo what I think was your own
interpretation that this is a Content
neutral provision it prohibits any
congregating or gathering within a zone
that is established it would prohibit
people who are uh on the other side of
the issue who might be pro-choice or
supportive of women from being in that
same Zone and courts historic have taken
a different perspective on restrictions
that implicate speech if in fact they
implicate all speech equally um and New
Hampshire's best example is the one that
you yourself referenced we have um a
statute that protects a certain Zone
around New Hampshire's electoral polling
places it prohibits all messages for for
being delivered in that zone and it does
it so that voters can enter and exit
freely uh without having
proximity or um uh too much interruption
in their space or too much interruption
in their message and so there are
analogies where similar laws like this
have been upheld and in fact are being
applied in New Hampshire um and so with
that as background and um concern for
what might happen if in fact this
legislature were to send a signal that
in fact there is not concern for the
type of protesting and the type of
balancing that this law takes in place
um and we would respectfully ask you to
reject House Bill 430 um and urge your
focus on laws and policies that will
expand Access to Health Care thank you
so much for the opportunity to be before
you thank you for your testimony
representative Sylvia do you have a
question a question for the chair did we
have a three minute limit this
afternoon uh I did not specifically
impose the thre minute limit although I
have been carefully watching People's
testimony and and uh people have been
very courteous this afternoon and not uh
speaking too long so thank
you is are there questions uh for
attorney
friselle seeing none thank you again for
your testimony today thank you for the
opportunity and Francis Hines is Francis
Hines
available
[Applause]
I know he was on the list of
attendees okay he should he's here so
unmute can you hear me we can hear you
okay uh good afternoon my name
is
go
ahead my name is Francis Hines I'm 74
years old and I've been a resident of
Windam New Hampshire for 47 years I'm
testifying in favor of House Bill 430
which will repeal an unconstitutional
law and once again allow free speech on
the public sidewalks in New Hampshire
most Wednesdays I travel to Manchester
New Hampshire to pray on the public
sidewalk in front of Planned Parenthood
a business engaged primarily in making
money aborting babies I pray that women
will not get an abortion that day and
choose life for their baby instead I
usually carry a religious sign with a
picture of Our Lady of guad Lupe or a
sign that says you hear this stuff God's
most precious gift huh rep
representative Lang you might want to
mute each Wednesday I wonder if this
will be the day that the police come and
take away our right to pray gather and
speak on the public sidewalk by
enforcing RSA
132 a law tailored for a single line of
business in the state only businesses
that make money doing abortions but no
other businesses it has a chilling
effect on First Amendment rights that
law doesn't apply to any other business
in New Hampshire if you end up with a
lemon for an automobile you can protest
in front of the dealership on the public
sidewalk if you dislike a bill proposed
by New Hampshire lawmakers you can
protest on the public sidewalk you're
not under constant threat of fines or
arrest like I am when execute exercising
my constitutional rights in front of an
abortion
business you know when you became a New
Hampshire State Rep you took an oath to
uphold the Constitution of the United
States of America and New Hampshire and
in 1968 when I became an officer in the
United States Air Force I took an oath
to support and defend the
Constitution so I ask you to support and
uphold both the United States and New
Hampshire constitutions and vote in
favor of House Bill 430 and repeal an
unconstitutional statute made
exclusively to prevent First Amendment
rights on the public sidewalks of New
Hampshire for a single money making
abortion business and ask you once again
to allow the citizens of New Hampshire
Free Speech thank you thank you very
much do uh does anyone have any
questions for Mr
Hines seeing none thank you for your
testimony Mr hin Mr chair I think
Kathleen Yan is back with
us okay and can you hear me yes hi can
are you there we are okay thank you very
much I appreciate uh the opportunity
today and uh my name is Kathy Anan I'm a
resident of Chester New Hampshire also a
retired nurse uh voter uh for over 35
years um but also a sidewalk advocate
for women and their children um and I
you like I say thank you for this moment
of free speech in my experience and
observations the sidewalk counselors and
Advocates have been peaceful polite and
helpful in offering Aid referrals to
community sources and information which
enables Clinic patrons to make a fully
informed decision about abortion at no
time in my experience of three years has
there been any blocking or interference
of any kind last month a mother decided
to speak with us prior to entering the
facility for her scheduled abortion she
was sad and distressed as she had
six-month-old baby at home upon
receiving information uh from us uh
support offer of continued help she
became teary but encouraged we talked
about her Irish twins and we smiled at
her and she smiled back she decided to
keep her baby that's why we're asking um
I'm asking you to please support Free
Speech please per please support our our
efforts to help women we're in no way um
there to hurt anybody to to as as things
were said today I've never seen it um
never seen any uh harassment or
interference and we're volunteers we're
not paid employees for you know like
Planned Parenthood business we are there
on our own time to help women and like I
say we we would support Free Speech
please thank you all does anyone have
any questions for Miss Yan
Zan thank you for your testimony
today there are three people left who
pre-registered to speak I understand
that other people may want to speak but
there are three left who pre-registered
to speak and that's Ian
huet uh Jason Hennessy and Delia
vidunas and I'll call upon Ian huet to
speak
good afternoon can you hear me we can
hear you thank you my name is Ian huitt
and I'm general counsel at Cornerstone
good afternoon and good to see you all
again and in addition to being an
attorney I've also published academic
work on constitutional issues so I'm
here to answer any tough legal questions
that you have about 4:30 or the
constitutionality or lack thereof of RSA
13238 and once again I've submitted
written testimony but I'd like to make
some corrections I think there have been
some mischaracterizations and
misunderstandings um to an extent even
on both sides of the discussion to what
the law is first of all the easiest
point to address is this issue of coming
into the lobby I don't think there's any
serious argument to be made that
repealing this law would allow people to
come into the lobby repealing this law
is not going to legalize trespassing or
disorderly conduct which are illegal in
New Hampshire the references we've heard
to the Harrisburg and the Pittsburgh
cases both of those at the United States
Supreme Court level were denials of C
tiari which means the Supreme Court just
declined to hear the case without
addressing the legal issues in the case
one way or another the Supreme Court
declined sir tiari all the time on all
kinds of cases for many different
reasons and in fact in a lot of cases
the Supreme Court will decline sirari in
a case that's basically identical to a
case it just heard the Supreme Court
can't micromanage all the courts in the
country so you know this is an
understandable mistake I think from from
lay people and from the media but I was
disappointed to hear an attorney appeal
to two denials of Sir tiari as legal
arguments and I can assure you that she
would not make that argument in New
Hampshire District Court where it would
not be heard as a legal argument I've
certainly not practiced in front of a
judge that would accept the denial of
sirari as if it were somehow binding
precedent ready V Foster which is the
New Hampshire district court case that
case the court was very clear that it
was denying the case based on lack of
standing the plaintiffs did not have
standing because a Zone was demarcated
and the district court judge made it
clear that if a Zone was demarcated
there would be standing I'd encourage
you all to just look through that
decision to see if there was substantive
constitutional analysis and there was
not the court did not do the kind of
analysis we saw in McCullen B cley which
was the Massachusetts case here here's
what happened in the Massachusetts case
the court found that there's a First
Amendment right to one-on-one
interaction so you don't just have a
First Amendment right to protest with
signs within sight of the clinic you
have a First Amendment right to extend
an outstretched arm in Peaceable
conversation or to distribute leaflets
so that's First Amendment conduct the
court Court found the Massachusetts law
was content neutral so it applied
intermediate scrutiny so it asked does
this burden substantially more First
Amendment conduct than is necessary for
the government's interest and the court
went through the different government
interests and it said well if they need
to prevent harassment they can use laws
against harassment or even pass those
laws if they don't exist um if there's
crowding they can pass laws against
crowding they shouldn't be burdening
speech so none of that analysis turned
at all on whether it was 35 ft or 25 ft
and the analysis did not turn on the
fact that the clinics in Massachusetts
didn't just demarcate these zones at
will all those relevant aspects are
totally the same in this case and in
fact there is one big difference I would
say and that is that our law is worse
our law has something the Massachusetts
law did not have which is a
discriminatory carve out for Clinic
escorts in the Massachusetts case and
I've encourage you all to look at this
the Supreme Court said it actually
counted in favor of Massachusetts
argument that their law did not have
quote unquote a carve out for the clinic
escorts expressly our law does have that
and so I think if anything the New
Hampshire law would be judged to be
content discriminatory not content
neutral it could be subject to strict
scrutiny and even Massachusetts in Molen
did not argue that their law could pass
strict scrutiny and of course if not
subject to strict scrutiny it'd be
subject to intermediate scrutiny and
would still lose and I'll take any
questions okay are there any questions
for Mr
hwit yes representative
Sylvia thank you Mr chairman thank you
Mr hu for taking my question
um could you speak to um RSA 132 colon
38 uh Roman 2 where it says that
reproductive Health Care Facilities
shall clearly demarcate the zones uh are
are these facilities doing this now I
don't think they are and I don't
understand why no they excuse me they
haven't done that yet if you look uh
later on in the statute there's a
provision saying that the statute has no
effect if a zone is not
demarcated so that is an option that the
clinics have they are not required to
demarcate the Zone if the Zone was was
demarcated it would confer standing and
there could be a lawsuit um in which
this law would be found
unconstitutional my suspicion as to why
the clinics have not demarcated a Zone
and I think this is candidly this is
good legal strategy on the part of the
clinics attorneys is that keeping this
law on the books has something of a
chilling effect we've heard I think some
indications of that today and actually
demarcating the Zone would result in it
being challenged and overruled I think
if the clinics really have the kinds of
interests that we've heard articulated
today they would be making use of the
Zone they're not making use of it I
think because they know that it is
unconstitutional and would be found
uncons thank you are there other
questions for Mr
huet yes representative Silber yes thank
you Mr chair thank you uh Mr hu just uh
a little inside baseball question uh
isn't it correct that the denial of
ciori by the US Supreme Court is not
considered precedent and that well over
90% of the applications for ciari are
denied each year yes that's exactly
right I totally agree and and as I
mentioned earlier the Supreme Court
denies C for many reasons um even cases
that are clearly in conflict with
President it has just issued and I a
major reason is of course that the
justices have a limited amount of time
we recently saw Chief Justice John
Roberts move around circuit assignments
because some justices like justice prer
were over taxed so they can only do a
fin outed amount of work and that
accounts for most Niles of C they
exactly as you said have no precedential
value thank
you and representative mlan yeah thank
you Mr chair and thanks for taking my
question just um to clarify for me and
maybe some of the other non-lawyers on
the committee if you could give me a
quick executive uh summary of some you
mentioned some different levels of
scrutiny you know based on yeah this is
a uh anyways if you could just maybe go
through some of those different levels
of scrutiny that you were talking about
strict scrutiny Etc it would help me
understand that a little bit better sure
well there's really two levels of
scrutiny that are important here the
Massachusetts law was subject to a kind
of narrow tailoring but you could call
it intermediate scrutiny so if a law
burdens speech like this law does but
the law is content neutral that is it it
doesn't discriminate against anyone's
particular views then the court will ask
well does it burden substantially more
speech than is necessary to achieve the
government's end so that's what happened
in the Massachusetts case um and at
least that level of scrutiny would apply
in our case now I suggested that the New
Hampshire law is content discriminatory
because of the carve out for Clinic
escorts and a Content discriminatory law
is that needs to meet a narrower narrow
tailoring standard and the standard
there is is it the least restrictive
means of satisfying the government's
interests and I'll point out that in
Molen when asked even Massachusetts did
not say that their law could satisfy
that level of scrutiny so I don't think
there's any question that ours would not
either thank
you any other
questions thank you Mr
huitt thank you and uh next witness
would be Jason
Hennessy
hello good afternoon good
afternoon hi so my name is Jason
Hennessy I'm a resident of amers New
Hampshire I'm also the president of New
Hampshire right to life and I'm here to
speak in favor of House Bill
430 um so I would submit to the to the
committee that this bill has very little
to do with abortion and much more to do
with how our government treats people
who are peacefully exercising their
constitutional rights on public
property um the there's two two major
constitutional rights here that are at
Play Free Speech which is in the US
Constitution First Amendment as well as
New Hampshire's uh constitution in
article 30 there's also the right to
peacefully assemble and that is also in
the First Amendment of the Constitution
and in article 32 of the New Hampshire
Constitution so the question I would ask
you is how does it make sense to single
out citizens who are pro-life to to qu
protected speech and assembly and let me
just read you an example uh or the text
from the statute of RSA 132 38 it says
no congregating
patroling picketing or demonstrating
between
science and so I would just ask you as
legislator legisl legislators how does
that fit with freedom of speech and
freedom of peaceful
assembly um and I also want to remind
you that we're talking here about public
property if this were talking about
private property that's an entirely
different story but this is public and
so why should a private abortion
provider be allowed to tell members of
the public what they can't say on public
property it doesn't make any
sense um uh the last part I'll I'll talk
about here is that um abortion providers
have already told us that they don't
want or need this law while their words
today say one thing their actions over
the last six years tell a completely
different story If This Were any sort of
issue you would ECT that abortion
facilities would will have taken
advantage of this law um but they've had
six years and they haven't and so um
I've heard no argument today that would
justify keeping the law in the books and
so I ask you to please repeal uh RSA 132
37 through 40 by voting OTP on HB 430
and with that I would love to take any
questions okay are there any questions
for Mr
Hennessy I see none thank you for your
testimony
today and our and the last person who
pre-registered to testify is Delia
theunis hello everyone good afternoon
can you hear me we
can okay thank you very much thank you
uh chairman Gordon and thank you all the
members of the committee um my name is
Dalia vidunas and I am the executive
director of a quality Health Center here
in conquer I'm also an escort um and I
want to testify here in opposition to
House Bill
430 I want to start off with is that I
totally wholeheartedly believe in the
freedom of speech what I don't believe
in is the ability of somebody to stand
less than six inches away from your nose
and scream at you in front of your face
a lot of times the protesters will say
to us that the only way can get out
their information about people's options
are by protesting however as one person
previously pointed out we have more
Right to Life Pregnancy uh crisis
pregnancy centers right to life crisis
pregnancy centers in the state of New
Hampshire then we do hospitals and
abortion providers combined so there's
plenty of places for people to get their
information what I am not wholeheartedly
for is the right to have is people's
right to go to the doctor to get a a
procedure done a legal procedure done
and be harassed as they do that no other
Medical Offices get protested while
trying to perform legal abort legal
procedures the same way as reproductive
right uh programs
do the conquered police department has
come to e EHC seven times and since
covid
started seven times in just over a year
and it's basically because people the
protesters have refused to maintain
distances they've not been wearing masks
um they called against one of our dogs
one time saying that the dog was
harassing them and therefore they wanted
the dog that one of the escorts had
arrested they are a nuisance not only to
our patients but also to the police
department with the number of calls that
they put into them about what escorts do
and about the number of calls we put in
because they refuse to obey the law and
refuse to obey the mask mandate here in
New
Hampshire they also take pictures as was
said before they take pictures without
people's permission and they take videos
and post them on YouTube as well as
their Facebook pages these are patients
that are coming in and out of our
facility without their permission these
things are being posted and they have no
idea why a person may have come into our
facility they also post pictures and
videos of the people that live in the
Kennedy Apartments next door to us
people that have mental health issues
and that may not understand the
convoluted questions that the protesters
are asking them end up being then put on
video because and being told that
they're being silly or how they don't
understand what life really is all about
because they can't answer that
information properly and I apologize my
phone is ringing I thought I put it on
mute what I'd like to do is talk to you
about three different scenarios that
just recently happened in front of our
facility because a quality Health Center
has been in business for almost 50 years
providing reproductive health care which
includes assisting people getting
pregnant as well as terminating
pregnancy several months ago we had
please imagine yourself this is what
happened that several months ago we had
a patient sitting in her car with her
partner petrified to come inside our
facility she wanted to get an ultrasound
adjust stational dating ultrasound done
because no other facilities in New
Hampshire were doing gational dating at
that time because of covid it was
considered an unnecessary procedure
wanted to come in just to make sure
where they were at to be able to go to
the doctors to an OB later because OBS
were not doing gestational dating at
that time either and they were
surrounded by protesters with dism
pictures of dismembered
fetuses they were there because of a
wanted pregnancy to get gestational
dating and their car was surrounded with
pictures of dismembered fetuses well of
course the couple then called us we had
to go get bring some escorts in to bring
them into the facility so that they
could have gational dating done this was
not for anything other than a regular
normal legal procedure a second case was
a woman had fetal
anomalies she's walking into the clinic
with her partner this was a wanted
pregnancy and the protesters screamed at
them saying be a man don't let her be a
murderer why don't you take control of
your household how can you let her do
that the woman when she walked into our
facility
crumpled on the
ground sobbing hysterically because she
was already convinced that the fetal
anomaly was her fault even though it
wasn't and then to have these protesters
call her a murderer and tell her partner
to be a
man um and the last one I want to talk
to you about is how we had a high school
somebody who just graduated high school
who thought she was being very
responsible who did not want to have a
pregnancy because she knew she could not
financially afford it did not have the
uh familial support and all that did not
want to be a burden on the system as she
was entering in here she was called a
loser because she was trying to make
what she thought was a good decision
about her life and called a murderer and
a
loser um
okay I don't want to rush you but if you
could sum up your testimony that would
be great
certainly I'm sorry people do have the
right to freedom to Speech but the
problem is is we don't know who's going
to be well behaved and who's not and
therefore we need to keep the bill the
buffer zone bill as is and have hp430 in
expediate to legislate to be able to
protect those people that don't deserve
to be screamed at that deserve to get
Good Health Care thank you thank you
representative rice do you have a
question yes thank you very much Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question
so by not repealing this you're saying
that this is going to help keep people
safe
yet earlier it's been testified to that
the buffer zone isn't even in in effect
that you your facility isn't using the
buffer zone so I don't understand why
repealing this is going to put more
people in
danger I'm not trying to be difficult I
do I do no no and actually I truly
appreciate the question because I
couldn't get to it in my testimony so
thank you um the issue is is that
sometimes we have protesters that are
extremely well- behaved sometimes we
don't approximately two years ago we
started to get this group that is
horrific and not well behaved and really
harassing what we started to do is we
then in began a new escort program
progam and I have been had been
documenting the times we were calling
the police what was happening and all
that I was already in conversations with
code enforcement the city solicitor City
selectman and the police department here
in conquered to talk about instituting a
buffer zone and then covid
hit with covid everything just kind of
has stopped uh we've lost staff I
haven't been able to hire in place and
we just don't have the person power at
this point what I was doing a year ago
to continue I would like to continue to
go forward but I needed to put a halt on
things
unfortunately thank you okay are there
any other questions for miss
vidunas seeing none thank you for your
testimony today that completes the that
completes the list of people who
pre-registered to testify today there
may be additional people who do wish to
testify and I see that there is a Beth
SC who has her
hind hi yes can you hear me we can yeah
my name is Beth scare and I live in NASA
I I help to coordinate the 40 Days for
Life sidewalk vigils um outside Planned
Parenthood in Manchester and the
equality Health Center in con
and I've been participating in these
vigils for many years 40 Days for life
is a peaceful 40-day prayer vigil held
twice a year our mission is to pray for
an end to abortion and to witness to the
community about the sanctity of
life and I have been very grateful the
for the relationship between 40 Days for
life and the staff at the Quality Health
Center when I see Dalia who we just
heard from the director of equality
Health Center or Eli couti the Outreach
coordinator we exchange friendly
greetings and small talk multiple times
Eli and I have had our picture taken
together the abortion workers are people
made in the image of God and we pray and
work for their protection as well as the
protection of the clients going into the
abortion facilities and their babies we
are there to be a peaceful and loving
Outreach to all inter and leaving the
abortion facilities and everyone passing
by um the buffer zone laws written is
unconstitutional and bans even peaceful
prayer on the public sidewalk and as
another person
said um even protesting high
rent
or stopping to smoke a cigarette uh
waiting for an Uber it bans everything
everything is banned on the sidewalk not
just speech but even being present
there and I would I'm asking you to
please vote ought to pass an HB 430 and
remove these unconstitutional
restrictions on our god-given freedom of
speech on the public right of way thanks
thank you Miss G are there questions
from Miss
G seeing none thank thank you again for
your testimony
today there there is a Melissa May who
wishes to
testify okay hi can you hear me we can
okay yeah thanks for listening to me
today I've been on this call the whole
time um I'm somebody on the sidewalks in
conquer and Manchester uh one
opportunity I'd like to share is in
Manchester I was on the sidewalk one day
and we go in the parking lot and there
was a couple there who didn't really
have the information they needed and did
not understand that abortion is killing
a child so we talked over the fence this
man was very open to hear um testimony
resources and he started to change his
mind um Planned Parenthood took the girl
in for an appointment and he was calling
her at the same time asking what was
going on as we talked I've eached out to
the resources I had uh the Pregnancy
Center in Manchester uh you know a home
for mothers to be able to take care of
their children everything for free he
changed his mind plan Parenthood also
decided to take her abortion in that day
because she was from a foreign country
if we had the time and resources to help
people really understand what abortion
is we could help them part two and this
will be quick is the reason why I
believe in freedom of speech is because
it's a right and as I'm in conquered and
we could go back and forth to even a
chemical spray in someone's eyes from
the escort we have the freedom to lie
and that's something whether we agree or
not we should have so thank
you thank you uh are there any questions
from
Isme seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you is there any is
there anyone else who wishes to testify
by today who hasn't had that
opportunity I see someone by the name of
Jessica
testify and Jessica if you could
identify yourself that would be helpful
yes hi can you hear me we can hi uh my
name is Jessica Goff and I am a citizen
of New Hampshire I just wanted to
testify quickly today um I didn't plan
to but I've been sitting in on the
hearing all day um and I just wanted to
testify uh a lot of the individuals who
we've heard today uh call themselves
sidewalk counselors and I would just
like to affirm that as a woman who has
been into Planned Parenthood for birth
control not for an abortion um I was not
stopped by individuals but I did feel
intimidated and had I not had support I
may have not gone into the facility not
gotten um needed birth control and then
ended up actually needing an abortion um
and these individuals while there are
individuals who just try to give
information counselor gives the idea
that this is desired um given the
internet given lots of resources in the
community if individuals wanted this
information they would seek it out
themselves and this is also given um by
medical providers um and so I just
wanted to to kind of put that out there
that even if uh with this 25 foot um
radius uh individuals could be 25 ft
away and then seek out um that Council
if they wished to have it but didn't
need to walk past faces um that were
shameful while they were trying to
receive needed care um thank you thank
you any questions people might have for
Jessica seeing none thank you for taking
the time to testify today thank you is
there anyone else who wishes to
testify I see no one so I will declare
that the hearing on house Bill 4:30 is
now
closed and uh thank everybody for their
patience today in particular with regard
to the technical difficulties we had at
the beginning of the afternoon we are on
for tomorrow morning at 9
o'clock I have received a note
indicating that they have to do some
work on the internet here in the
building and have asked us to complete
our hearings by 4 o'clock tomorrow and I
certainly hope we'll be able to do that
so and in the event is there any other
business that we yes uh representative
MC Beth thank you chairman Gordon I'm
wondering if you could read the tally of
pro and con people that signed the blue
sheet or register it online thank you I
can uh but I don't have it with me
because I went in the other room so we
could avoid the technical difficulties
but if you wait just a second I'll be
right back
thank you Mr
chairman
on House Bill 622 the original uh the
first one of the first two bills we
heard first thing this
morning 77 people uh registered in
support of that bill and
729 registered in opposition to that
bill
representative Gordon do we have any way
of telling who's from New Hampshire and
who's not on those
signups uh yes oh well no not really uh
I don't really the only thing that I can
tell is by telephone number so I can
look at the area codes on there and
clearly the the vast majority are 603
area codes there are some other area
codes but you can't really tell from the
area codes because people get different
area codes when they get different
phones so uh in particular cell phon
so I'd like to tell you that for sure
but I don't know Mr chairman Mr chair
yeah M Mr chairman I I asked Jason
Osborne to have the IT people change
that online registration form to
indicate a place for them to show their
town of residence he said they're
working on it that that would be great
uh I I have to tell you when I picked
the witnesses today I picked the 603
area codes as we went through the
witness list uh first and gave them
priority in most
cases Mr chair yes well first of all our
right to no laws um apply equally to
people inside and outside of New
Hampshire so we certainly couldn't ban
anyone from ifying or signing never
suggested anyone should be banned please
don't put words in my mouth I'll also my
second Point well I'm just expressing my
opinion I wasn't putting words in
anybody's mouth but my own and the other
thing is the only i a not of I kept
track of everybody who spoke uh during
the hearing of most of their names in
625 and the only person I
remember acknowledging out the state was
uh where Colleen the woman who's the
president of Americans United for life
which is DC based uh source so even um
you know so probably that was primarily
I doubt that she was and she was um you
know against the bill so I certainly
don't think those 729 people have a
disproportionate number of out of state
residents in there so probably
uh this probably the vast majority of
these were people from in state and U
and as I said The only person who
actually I recall saying she was from
out of state and certainly her was the
uh head of Americans United for life
which the DC based group certainly
entitled to be interested in the issues
these bills
so clear clear clearly the vast majority
of people who signed up had 603 area
code so yeah the with regard to House
Bill
625 there there were
576 people who registered in support and
735 who registered in
opposition
and with regard to House Bill
430 there were
259 who registered in support and
632 in
opposition thank you very much your
honor appreciate it and that that was as
of uh noon time
today and I because I I saw people were
still sending us emails even into the
afternoon uh is there any other business
that we need to address this
afternoon as I said earlier I uh and I
don't know if it was a problem with the
technical difficulties but I tried to
get a schedule for the 17th they're
unable because there just aren't any
hearing rooms to hold it on the 17th and
so we're and the following week we have
two weeks of session so we'll only have
one hearing day that
week uh the on the 20
23rd after that we definitely need to do
two days a week if there aren't hearing
rooms available we may have to do what
some other committees have apparently
done and that is just uh a a
full um
non uh a hearing uh just on online just
as plain Zoom hearing and everybody
being remote and to do it that
way and but I'll try to get them
scheduled and and let you know as soon
as I know the
dates and is there any other business
thank you Mr representative Langley did
you have something I did um thank you Mr
chair I I wanted to apologize to the
committee for leaving my speaker on and
to thank you for letting me know that it
was on not not a problem representative
Alexander um thank you Mr chair um do we
have any early bills that we have to
pass yes not we we have five early bills
and we have exe we'll have executive
session on the afternoon of the
16th and we'll get out the early bills
and as many other bills as we can that
day
uh and so if you do if you are going to
offer amendments on any bills you need
to make sure that they're prepared for
that
afternoon we uh and and thank you the
for the three people who did the
committee reports on the bills that
we've already
exacted
and Mr chairman yes
um Mr chairman I just want I I made a
comment earlier and I'd like to repeat
it last week when we had to because of
snow have everything remote the entire
day went through without a problem today
the only problems seem to come from the
difficulties um taking place in the
committee room um um so I wonder if you
would consider the
possibility of denying yourself the
pleasure of being in the LLB and just
conducting these uh hearings uh all
remotely and then perhaps we could meet
next on on the 16th and on the 17th
which would help a lot we have more
bills than anybody else and um we're
going to have a hard time giving them
the kind of attention that they deserve
if we don't have more meeting times so
it's just a suggestion and um I don't
know if there are other factors at play
but we did do it without you did it
without a hiccup last week when it was
all done in
absentia
y uh well that's a possibility I I one
of the limitations isn't just the uh
committee rooms it's the number of Zoom
licenses that they have as well so I can
check I can check to see whether that is
in fact
possible and I and I will check
representative
Smith thank you very much Mr chair and
thank you again for doing a terrific job
these days are not
easy well I I think the committee the
committee was was uh is has just been
terrific and to see that everybody is
here again today uh and has been all
along it's uh it's a pleasure to be a
chairman when you know you have the
committee there to provide you with
support yes representative
trer thank you Mr chair just wondering
will you be getting a link for
tomorrow's meeting you already have you
should should have already received it
they came in at the same time I think
okay CU I know this morning that was the
problem I was having sir is I didn't get
a link that's why had to call in and I
didn't see one for
tomorrow it looks like J Jennifer's
still on the call so she could probably
make sure yeah I um you should receive
at 8 am a reminder invitation in your
inbox and if you ever have a problem
feel free to reach out to me if you
don't receive that by 8 CL and you're
looking for it just um send me an email
and I can copy and paste your invite in
my response okay great thank
you yeah any other business
today thank you so much everybody okay
thank you you take care bye bye
bye